this is jockle podcast number 183 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening not one of the
guys on the ground at like this mission
now moving to within a click of their
target they had pushed that distraction
from their minds and were solely focused
on the deadly challenge before them
glancing at the GPS attached to the
stock of his rifle and scanning the
terrain ahead
Lieutenant Commander James Reese called
a quick perimeter snipers were already
moving up to the high ground as team
leaders joined Reese for a last quick
update before the final push to the
objective even with all the technology
at their disposal things could go wrong
in a heartbeat their enemy was cunning
and highly adaptive after 16 years at
war the Afghan saying the Americans all
have the watches but we have all the
time rang a bit more true than head in
the early days what do you think Reese
asked a huge beast of a man looking like
a creature from another world with his
aor1 patterned camouflaged body armor
and ops core half shell helmet with nods
firmly in place Reese looked at his most
seasoned troops Eve the light green glow
of the nods illuminated through the
beard on the man's face a slight smile
that could not be mistaken for anything
other than the confident look of a
professional Special Operations soldier
it's just over the rise replied predator
shows nothing moving those centuries
noting his troop chief nodded
alright guys he said to the other four
men in the circle let's do it
they rose with resolve and moved with
the poise of men who were comfortable in
chaos
moving up the rocky ridge line to get
their teams in place before approaching
the target
to make entry this is too easy you're
thinking too much again it's just
another mission then why this feeling
maybe it's just the headaches the
headaches had plagued Greece for the
past several months finally prompting a
visit to Balboa Naval Medical Center
before this deployment for a series of
tests
still no word back from the docks
maybe it's nothing but maybe it's
something Reese had learned a long time
ago that if something didn't look right
then it probably wasn't that judgment
had kept him and his men alive on many a
deployment everything had lined up a
little too easy for this target the
Intel the offset infill the current
state of the objective area and why the
pressure from higher authority to go
after this target when was the last time
a flag level command injected itself
into a tactical planning process
something wasn't adding up maybe
everything's fine
maybe it's the headaches maybe it's a
bit of paranoia and maybe I'm getting
too old for this
focus Reese this wasn't the first time
that they had approached a target they'd
suspected was a possible ambush at one
point in the war when Intel had pointed
to the high possibility of an ambush
corroborated by multiple sources both
human and technical Reese will bear 84
or a few 105 rounds from an ac-130
gunship this was the first time that
actual tactics had been dictated from
hire from men who would not be on the
ground focus on the mission Reese one
more check with the Tactical Operations
Center a forward based command also
called the talk and a look at the
predator feed nothing
another check with the sniper teams
nothing moving Rhys glanced up at the
military crest of the hill in front of
him through his nods he could see the
assault teams set and ready to move he
couldn't see the snipers which gave him
cause for a thoughtful smile best in the
business
Rhys keyed his radio and open open his
mouth to give the order to move then it
all went black
the explosion knocked Rhys back ten
yards and ripped his helmet from his
head as the entire military crest of the
hill in front of him erupted in a
concussion of violence and death
teammates friends husbands and fathers
who one moment earlier had represented
the best spas of Special Operations
force in the world were gone in less
than a second
somewhere a true believer is training to
kill you he is training with minimum
food or water in austere conditions day
and night
the only thing cleaning on him is his
weapon and he made his web gear he
doesn't worry about what workout to do
his rock weighs what it weighs his runs
and when the enemy stops chasing him the
true believer doesn't care how hard it
is he only knows that he wins or he dies
he doesn't go home at 1700 he is home he
only knows the cause and those right
there are two excerpts from two books
the first one a book called the terminal
list and the second book a book called
true believer and these books are
fiction they are novels and with the
exception of the novel Musashi by Elie
yoshikawa I have not covered any novels
on the podcast but I'm actually not here
to talk about those novels the novels
these books were written by a seal a
seal that I knew and a seal that is here
with us tonight to share his experiences
in the teams what he learned how he
ended up where he did as a retired seal
officer
a husband a father and a writer of
fiction
his name is Jack car welcome to the show
thank you so much for having me on
it's great to be here yeah man good good
to finally get you out here I know we
tried to hook this up for a little while
yep it's uh it's good and you sent me
your latest book and I said to myself
okay well let's just make this happen
awesome so yeah man let's talk a little
bit about you well that's hard you but
I've never heard that true believer read
quite so well so I used to read that to
my guys in the teams and then read your
laws of combat read those two that I'm
in and that one would you know just kind
of set the stage about what the Syria
who were going after here yeah and then
your laws of combat which of course I
yeah pass on everybody ever worked with
ever since Ronald they probably found a
couple of them in the book for those
that hey there's a couple I put him in
italics you know I took you to credit
okay jack so let's let's talk a little
bit about you know where it all started
yeah well like your what year were you
born yeah 73 okay no I'm kind of a young
and am i well what are you 71 okay yeah
yeah now a child of the 80s though you
know this formative years were 80 to 89
and you grew up in NorCal NorCal and my
mom is librarian from a very early age
this we use a little area or city area
row yeah
but not you rural small town it's a
small town yep yeah so north of San
Francisco sure but well today is d-day
so probably appropriate we talked about
that my grandfather was killed in World
War two some very early age I was
surrounded by those silk matthews an
aviator marine flew the Corsair which
was that plane the gold wings that would
fold up right about that time there was
a the show Black Sheep squadron Ono on
TV I went to an airshow and met Pappy
Boynton before he passed away he got his
book signed and so I always knew that
the military was where I was going
just earlier on I'd know exactly what
that was gonna be but do you ever think
about trying to be a pilot
you know fleetingly I'm sure I did
Marine Corps fleetingly as a pilot just
following the footsteps of my
grandfather but and it became very
obvious that the my skillset lay in a
more primal level on the ground it was
just attracted to that for some reason
probably a lot of you know well in the
DNA for sure but also the influence of
popular culture the books and movies
that I read growing up those are the
guys that I that I wanted to be like and
had backgrounds that I I wanted to have
one day but my grandfather didn't make
it back from from World War two so he
was killed off Okinawa in 1945 in May so
near the end of the war and but his his
wings made it back old pictures of his a
black-and-white pictures of his squadron
him by his plane the silk maps that give
80 years back then except they hit the
water with paper it just disintegrates
so had these silk maps so I just grew up
with him really as kind of the ideal
hero I guess obviously never met him and
neither did my dad it was a born wall he
was deployed
so uh so grew up with just knowing if
the military was my calling there was
never anything else I wanted to do and
then early on I found out what seals
were and your mom was a librarian yep
yep still is to this day
and so were you into reading yep yeah I
grew up surrounded by books and yeah
it's always naturally gravitated when I
would got to be about fifth grade I'd
say towards the things that the adults
are reading at the time so Tom Clancy
David Morrell Nelson DeMille age a
quenelle JC Pollak mark Holden these
guys in the 80s that had protagonists
with seal backgrounds or CIA backgrounds
or were Special Forces background so not
having the internet and not having that
many non-fiction books written about
seals that's what I read and I knew this
is where I'm going and then after that's
done I want to write fiction like these
guys so those are the two things that I
wanted to to do with my life how old
were you and you actually found out
about the SEAL Teams in fifth grade
seven so second grade second grade yeah
you found out about the SEAL Teams yep
from what so back then there were four
channels back then growing up so there
was an ABC CBS NBC and then that one
outlier channel that always had some
World War two movie on it going all the
time
I was a remote control back in the late
70s so Sundays were football days and I
was not interested in football at all
but I was interested in that war movie -
his playing opposite football so at a
commercial
my dad would look at his watch I can
still remember it to this day sit on the
couch and say go and I'd have two
minutes to run up change that channel to
that outlier channel and then sit back
down watch that movie and then he'd say
turn it back back to football two
minutes later so I got to do that and
and I just wade through the football
parts and then run up and change it to
whatever war movie was playing so this
causes attention deficit disorder
without money he had the train that are
incredible patience and imagination you
gotta fill in the blanks direct that
during the ballet it might be it and
yeah so one of those movies was the
frogmen and it showed these guys
climbing up over the beaches ahead of a
conventional force landing and putting
explosives on these obstacles and asked
my dad hey who are these guys and he
said those are frogmen and I said okay
what's a frogman he said ask your mother
so so I did and then we went down to the
local library cuz she would take any any
excuse to get us to the library and do
research show us I use the Dewey Decimal
System pull out the card things the
whole deal and did a little research and
there was hardly anything written back
then there was a couple magazines that
had mentions of seals a couple
non-fiction books that had a chapter or
a paragraph or two on seals much at all
and but my takeaway was that these guys
are touted anyway as one of the most
elite fighting forces in the world and
the training is the toughest ever
devised by our modern military arguably
that was my day away that's the same
thing we all know that's that's all
arguable there's all kinds of different
hard parts of all different training yep
I never went to Ranger School and if I
did go eating them already one MRE a day
I really not be a happy camper a little
but you know so everyone's got their
little double challenges and I heard the
same thing exactly so they had me and
yeah and you find out that it's a so
what did you do did you start preparing
for it physically yep
oh yeah everything are doing everything
I did from that so I guess I'm doing an
early form of CrossFit I guess before
before CrossFit was a thing in high
school so not in the you know in the
younger years you're high out still
playing soccer you're running around
cross country doing a lot swords but I
do credit cross country in those hills
in Northern California
with giving me for whatever reason that
no never quit
I see people stopping on the hill that
was give me and you like a pretty good
run I was okay yeah I was good but there
were some guys that were really really
good mine was just you know dogged
determination really so I was pretty
good but not the greatest and you know
but I loved it when I'd see people
walking especially on the hills when
people from the flatlands would come up
to our horse and and they'd hit that
first hill and walk it would just
devastate them and that which is I just
feed off that kind of like in hell week
when people would quit and I always feel
bad talking about this but I mean it's
true some people would say come back no
don't quit come back I didn't say one or
this is exactly this is what this
program is designed to do and so I kind
of fed off that I guess I love that
especially when the biggest strongest
fastest guys for those first three weeks
or whatever it was abuzz with the first
couple sounds just studs just quitting
first couple of hours said oh no people
said that was gonna happen
yeah and it did and I'm studs where I
thought to myself wow this guy seems
like a complete stud you know mentally
physically Cal just legit and then just
go wait amp right away how is that I
don't know but I would look at these
guys when I first showed up the buds I
guys huge Wow and he and he's doing
great climbing these ropes he's never
seen his legs and like oh my can look
and go on those monkey bars things and
geez how I'm not gonna make it through
if this guy this guy like there's a guy
like that here and it quits I see how
this works
yeah your men I get weak exactly I can
do this yeah so so you did running yeah
you did cross the country yep early on
did that stuff soccer lacrosse in in
high school but then I'd ride my bike to
school which was I don't know how long
at least ten miles I guess so early
morning during the California cold and
it was part of training and I get home
and we had this kind of play set
whatever from when we were kids and and
I do you know pull up cell he's holding
different you know it's trying to trying
to make an obstacle course for myself
when I got home and I would be knocking
out like 20 pull-ups at whatever 13 14
years old
and then go have like some pasta or a
piece of bread with butter you're not on
it for my snack
and and started training hard training
martial arts pretty early too but I was
searching there's a local Taekwondo
place right and you're doing some kata
stuff and you're learning a little bit
and you even hear how old were you
that would probably be fresh but 14
let's say so even as a 14 year old
you're like wow like this seems like it
many work but it also seems neck what if
someone hits me in the face
Yeah right 13-year old yeah kind of
picked up on that yep which is I could
be credit well cuz I'm guys can be
convincing you know yeah that's how you
see these videos of people online that
are making people fall down by a coining
out of metal and yelling their GI Adam
high now it's like this people literally
fall down them and start shaking it's
crazy yeah it's crazy
I can't grew up also like talk about
that the influence of popular culture so
you know Rocky movies I was just wow man
that's fighting right there I want to
learn how to do that how do I learn how
to do that in Northern California well
there wasn't really a place to go but
that that tenacity you know that getting
up every time you get knocked down like
I think those things really wore off on
me like I took that seriously and still
do to this day
what kind of music were you listening to
I really do the music thing tell uh the
last few years really it was like quiet
yep yeah I realized I'm starting to give
music less credit than I used to first I
used to look it I used to when I meet
people are talking for a little bit I'd
go how kind of music did you listen to
growing up because it would always kind
of fill me in about kind of who they
were because when when we grew up you
you only listen to what you kind of you
didn't get exposed to a bunch of stuff
you kind of had to figure it out then go
down that channel and so if you listen
to heavy metal okay I see you know I see
what you were doing or you listen to you
know Leonard Skynyrd okay cool I get
where I get I can you could just kind of
know because people wouldn't say because
what does everyone say now what do you
listen do they say everything because
everything's free and they can listen to
all this different kinds and it's just
wide open and that's what all these kids
say nowadays I listen to everything a
little bit of everything and so don't
offend anyone
yeah and so you just weren't even into
music no not till I got my driver's
license and then it kind of y'all had to
because you had other people in the car
and they bring a cassette tape on the
mixtape and put that thing and for
whatever reason when I grew up people
listened to stuff like 60s 70s my dad
had a barracuda and the the car like
this point I don't know three Barracuda
yellow with and it what and you're
saying no impressed yeah but it was not
because it was it was my dad being a
broke teacher needed a new car and went
out and paid whatever eighteen hundred
bucks for this car that was rusty but it
had an eight-track in it that's nice and
my dad I think he had one 8-track and it
was Hank Williams like Hank look that's
was it
yeah and Williams senior you know we
listen to a lot of Hank Williams when I
was growing up we had Kenny Rogers yeah
he has the gambler I'm sorry to hear
that we have the gamble every morning
dropped out for school wasn't an
eight-track I think my dad was an early
adopter exactly and I remember to this
day every day on the way to school was
it the gambler yeah all right so what
did your dad do I was an attorney at
that time then got into real estate
then cars later on and then retired
early it's okay so you're you're now at
what point did you say okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna go for sure like at what point
was this ten years old was this twelve
years old seven seven years old yeah
this is what I'm doing I'm going and
what made you decide any anything else
significant from high school you're
you're playing soccer you're playing
lacrosse yeah running you're running
pull-ups on the monkey back in whatever
trail running and all that sort of thing
just getting ready thinking about about
my next steps and knowing that there was
gonna be a little bit of pause there to
go to college first just in case because
we have to have contingency plans so you
looked and said like okay I'm gonna go
to college yeah yeah that person I need
to do that cuz I needed to get stronger
bigger faster and I thought I needed to
anyone don't know if that's the case or
not but probably not but you were just
more humble and you were saying hey I
need to be in better shape and I thought
there was eight guys on a SEAL team and
I was gonna be one of those guys and if
I was gonna be one of those guys I
needed to be in the best possible shape
and at that time the best possible shape
looked like still
and looked like Arnold so I did not look
like either of those guys so and I still
don't I never did but but I thought and
hit the iron here I need to get boxing
and I did a little bit in high school so
so fat go back to that martial arts
school the Taekwondo thing there was an
instructor there that kind of knew that
this wasn't quite the deal like a brown
belt in Taekwondo and then for my last I
guess year and a half of high school he
wanted to start his own thing and so
he'd I'd go pick him up in my car he
didn't have one and go to local park and
we bucks and it was like yeah reverse
hook you know the basics and and that
was awesome one smell theory I
absolutely love it the lard is plenty
for yes exactly the one through the up
might learned about a takedown was you
know like because he did some wrestling
Oh got to do a little of that
this guy's early and exactly exactly
yeah he had a car yeah he's still doing
it today yeah Mike Valentine is navin
seen him in years but he has a place up
in Northern California and he's still
still doing it and as soon as he found
out about jiu-jitsu he was doing that oh
good she was driving in San Francisco
and working out with whoever was the San
Francisco guy and the early 90s I guess
and yes we're talking about health
Gracie I don't know Charles Gracie labor
there's a bunch of options up there yeah
but nobody's really doing that nobody
was mixing stuff up like that I knew
about anyway
and we're my little town of whatever it
you know however many people it was but
then I just kept on that path just kept
and I thought it was gonna be a lifelong
path and but I peeked in about 95 and
that was in college yeah so you so you
end up going to college and what do you
would you go to study college for well I
wanted well I want to get out of there
as soon as possible so I get to the SEAL
Teams and so justice studies seem to be
the criminology seem to be the thing
that you could just hey that's kind of
interesting and I can get through this
thing in four years and get to the teams
and your backup plan would have been
been some kind of cop or something like
that I guess but I didn't really waste
too much time thinking about a back-up
plan I just knew that the college having
that degree was the back-up plan but I
figured that out later it was full-on
devoted to figuring out how to get to
the teams and then be in the best shape
I could mentally physically spiritually
before I got
when did you go to a recruiter what year
of college after I finished Oh sir after
you finished college I thought it was
gonna be like Forrest Gump like you you
go to the recruiter and there's a bus
waiting outside and you walk through and
you get on the bus and off you go
no totally yeah until you do it I mean I
did research enough to find out that
there was something called a dive ferrer
program and my Myra who didn't even know
what it was but I was in the back of a
book and I forget the name of the book a
paperback book that talked about all
sorts of different special operations
and again it had like one paragraph on
how to get to those places and but the
still it said die affair program so I
went in there it was kind of a scam I
did I did that program through total
scams like they get you to sign on for
six years and they say you get you
guaranteed a chance to spend it to try
out I want to guarantee to try out
that's all I need and then you get to
boot camp everybody got a chance in when
I was there anyway to try I signed up
for 60s guys for four and we all got the
chance
dang it but anyway I ended up spending
the 20 years in anyway yeah so you you
what year was it that you actually
enlisted in the Navy 96 96 so got caught
and I thought like I said I was gonna
walk on that bus and then I'm training
and I rolled my ankle and I'm like oh
man that's gonna be the end and I can't
believe it's like this huge I thought
was broken ended up just being you know
whatever that's brain yeah nothing less
reassuring whatever it's how like we're
glue 21 and yep that's how you think I
sing this black and blue ankle that's
huge and it's at home and what did I do
lost your brother Benjamin why was it
raining that day I just think I should
just relaxed not gotten hurt and then
sold on crutches for a couple months and
then got back after it and got the pool
how long was it from the time you
enlisted until the time you shipped out
you know there's all those things you're
supposed to do ahead of time when you're
on what do they call them you're
supposed to be going to class and
they're there I didn't do anything
yeah I didn't do any of that stuff
though cuz it was encouraged but I
somewhere I found out it was not
mandatory her and I was like okay good
because I don't want to have to you know
do whatever these ten push-ups with
these people I needed a actually
training was it a month's though no was
it was months yeah I was near snow it
was like five months like five months or
something yeah that's just a like a
little heads-up to people like you think
what like what you thought which is what
I thought
hey once I sign up I'm just gonna get on
a bus that's cool I'm good yeah and
really you could gear to go survive for
another five months as much as you're
waiting to go see have certain billets
allowed and all this stuff so it's kind
of a pain yep and you got to do the
medical stuff the gentle stuff take the
ASVAB and all that sort of thing to get
ready so those couple trips over the
main recruiting station to do all those
sorts of things get everything work in
line and then then off you go so and
then I was in now they have it for all
the people they're gonna be in some sort
of naval special warfare yeah
something it's more squared away yeah
exactly go through like they'd go to
they go to Chicago I think for eight
weeks get ready for buds yeah so you
showed up two buds were you ready for
buds as I always as ready as one could
possibly be mmm with all that training
all that thought I knew hey there's no
way I'm quitting because all my friends
I'm growing up knew that I wanted to do
this since I was seven and so there's no
way I'm quitting to die I can't go home
yeah and tell him I didn't make it you
know what's weird as people do that
right there and they still quit yeah
which boggles my mind I the the quitting
thing is hard for me to comprehend and
when I hear about people doing it like
people like that you know there was a
guy that killed himself recently and he
was that guy and and he had told
everyone I'm gonna be a seal and he had
trained for it he prepared for it and he
looked like a stud he looked like a
beast of a kid and he played lacrosse
and he was varsity this and Captain to
that I mean and then he got two buds and
for whatever reason he quit and then he
and then he killed himself
and you just think man like whatever
they're telling you in buds
you don't quit that's it just don't quit
it's pretty easy yeah just do not quit
and I know they play psychological games
on people of saying you know I'll say
you don't belong here
and all this kind of stuff I don't even
remember if they said that's me I didn't
care what they said to me it wasn't here
at penetrating you know anything in my
brain but but you know that's what they
do they they'll say oh you don't belong
here we don't want you on the team and
somebody that's sensitive to that it can
get through to ensure and make them
start believing
that the instructors actually the
structures are gonna leave and go order
a pizza they don't they're not actually
thinking about that you know no but they
take some kid and they quit and and you
know what good like you said like good
that if someone has that if someone is
gonna quit please quit during buds yeah
for sure there's got such a full metal
jacket I mean there's all these movies
that the show drill instructors and what
it's like in a yellow to make game
scream it's your theater merit game did
you have any trouble with anything about
so I swam before I got there and I'd
wake up super early week the master swim
program at five in the morning because I
knew Fleming was my weak point I mean I
swam I had no problem swimming but I
wasn't a competitive swimmer it was so
much more prepared for buds than me I'm
just like even the fact that you analyze
like what your strengths and weaknesses
were I was just it worked out yeah I was
yoga to which is beneficial you know
it's beneficial just to be young cuz
you're just gonna adapt right I mean
your brain isn't even completely
developed right so you're what 2014 like
that so why not 1819 years ago I was
just full full adaptation yeah whatever
they're doing that's what you have to do
in life in general
but but remember that I just distinctly
remember going to the pool so I'm
rehabbing my ankle at this point and I'm
going the pool now and it's it's
outdoors and this is wrong three buds
like nuts no but that frost layer of
frost on the pool deck so once you got
it was actually kind of warm but you
should have to walk across that pool
deck and jump in with these people that
are way older but way faster I was
definitely the slowest person in this
masters swim program was these people
would swim competitively and I ate their
45th which was old man I'm 42 years old
in your life and they're swimming at 5
in the morning today but so I decided
that I was prepared for the water level
and I grew up in the water essentially a
couplet and scuba diving at age nine I
was comfortable in the water which
helped dollar once again you are so much
more prepared perfect
he's like you know well I mean I I knew
I was I could swim and I surfed as a kid
and that helped but I definitely wasn't
scuba diving yeah almost died free
diving for abalone up north so I spend
with all this green I would know if I do
that now it's like a great white
breeding ground up there for sure but
abalone was amazing I love that we camp
out up there and just have a great time
but but even though I've prepared like
that the swims were hard and that first
one because it's that underwater
recovery stroke in 1996 they didn't
teach you now they teach you how to do
this thing yeah now they just get in the
water
here's your little basics here's how you
do it bring your head up whatever so I'm
like what's stroke is this none of the
books talked about this and we try to do
it we did the same ask for it was not in
the master swim program and I was third
to last I remember getting out of that
first woman they pair everybody up and
whatever they call up the two weeks
before you class up whatever that thing
is called and I was like third tool and
I can staggering out of the water like I
put out on this thing and I'm like wow
what's anyway they pair me up with this
really slow guy and I think he quit
right away so then they paired me up
with somebody else who was faster so I'm
barely making the swims in first phase
and then one of the guys in that class
was a water polo player from like USC or
something like that and he's like hey
want me to teach you how to do this
stroke yeah it'd be great and so we went
out behind the barracks thing and went
out learned you know in the ocean and he
just showed me how to do it and I went
from being third to last to the next
swim I was third there you go that was
awesome
and I was never throw it again I was
like faith or say whatever but we're
going from third to last I distinctly
remember to then coming out third after
learning the stroke I got this it's
different to swimming with fins to and
the way they teach you to do it is a
little bit different whatever but now
they prepare now you're preparing you
don't end physically like that that
eight weeks they spend in in Chicago
they learned the strokes they learned
how to lift the logs and not hurt
themselves and how do you know I used
there's instructions on how to lift the
log see sure know how to climb the ropes
mental toughness classes all that stuff
cuz they want but you know what happened
of course once those guys showed up and
they were expecting a lot more SEALs to
come through now because they needed
more in 2003 five four five six we need
more seals so let's do this program and
now we just got the fitter quitters and
so same that's the crazy thing yeah the
crazy thing is the attrition rate
doesn't change exactly
fitter quitter sitter quitters I like
that mm-hmm
because it doesn't matter how many
pull-ups you can do I mean it doesn't
matter and people say is it mental or
physical
it's definitely both if you can't do if
you can't climb a rope you're not making
it through it does matter how bad you
well if you've ever put in the work
you're not gonna be able to climb a rope
yeah oh yeah you can get some fitter
quitters exactly I always did any
average high school athlete physically
can make it through it so but it's the
my obviously metal part there that comes
in and you get guys that are in amazing
shape guys that were Olympic athletes or
whatever it is and they quit right away
and I think a lot of that like the guy
that killed himself maybe maybe you
hadn't you know faced adversity you know
me in the ways that you need to to
figure out how to actually over a
comment and how to get knocked out and
you know moving forward and you're gonna
get hurt you're gonna play hurt and a
lot of these guys aren't used to that
they're used to be being treated in a
way or if they're hurt they have a
someone's right there yeah they're
making sure that they're okay and
they're going to rehab and all that
stuff it's not you know they're like
Lamborghinis they're going to the shop a
lot there's no one that really crushes
buds now I don't think that just like oh
yeah everything was easy cuz there would
be some really good athletes and I did
have some stud athletes in my tonight my
honor man was a guy named Keith Chimaera
who was just a beast
you just fast at everything and strong
he's just a beast you know and so I
would say there I guess there are a few
guys that crush buds but most people
they're gonna have some they're gonna
pick apart some weak points in you yep
that's what you want I wanted to be
tested that was the whole that was one
of the main draws it's like I don't you
see I can did you make it through first
time every time
no after hell week my fists ladies
weren't working whatever stress
fractures whatever whatever it was so
they yanked me off the next swing was
always just sinking probably and said
you're going to medical of course no I'm
not go to medical ever exactly I mean I
remember that pulling me out out of the
boat
are going to medical now dang it so I
went in there and but it worked for me
whatever they did like some people
stayed there at that time like you could
you have a guy there for a year just
kind of hiding out but for me it worked
it doesn't it makes need a little rest
and then last up with the next class the
next class what was your attitude when
you got rolled was it like the end of
your life free like oh my god or were
you like okay cool I'm there because so
many people get rolled back yeah yeah
you know and I was little bummed because
I friends with all these guys they're
going on to dive phase and you're like
you're watching them going to die of a
as he's there but then a lot of them get
rolled back for pool cough and you've
got half your class back so that was
great and pool cough was my favorite
like that and drown proofing because
that's the only time you get to get
physical an instructor the other time
like you're just there you're getting
you're getting yelled at you being told
you're worthless you know whatever but
this is the time where it's mono e mono
they're like you against them and you
know it's a little bit physical so I
love pool comp pass first time I'm most
comfortable in the water but then the
drown proofing also that's what you
really get in physical they have those
different types of bodies that you have
to say if you mean life-saving yeah so
they have the guys just on there you
know just like a dead weight and then
one that's fighting you and that's the
one I liked yeah that was awesome and
they dragged you to the bottom and I
just feel like and this probably martial
art stuff just relax because he's
working he's working to keep me down
there at the bottom and then when he
comes up for air then I just go a little
a little more and then he'd get his air
and he dragged me back down but it was
like us together like I love that part
my favorite part I know what I figured
out and I figured out what the choke
hold right I figured out like okay this
is a choke like a rear-naked choke that
I can use and the recovery is you you I
think you put your arm over like almost
same but you grab them like by the lat
on the other side and I just realized oh
if I just put here it's gonna choke this
dude and it's gonna make him like get
under control and then boom I can go
back to position B I had a good time
with that
I failed pool comp yeah because the
former UDT guy from Nam who ended up
working for me at trade ed and and one
day I asked him I said you know do you
remember family and pool comp he goes
out yeah I was just messing with you
I was like oh cool
yeah that's awesome appreciate it and
then I passed the next time but yeah
yeah those those the water I was pretty
comfortable comfortable in from surfing
growing up but this for me everything I
had to work hard
I don't run hard all that stuff oh yeah
that's all things that's what it's all
about so you get done with buds and
where'd you have it going 25 and you
know back then you're like oh what's
gonna happen Oh
North Korea's gonna happen yeah I've got
a career leading stuff in the end and
still gonna happen
give me the news so I want you team five
that was my first choice and pretty just
because of that so now it's 1997 1997
yeah yeah so I was still on the west
coast at this time I was over at team
one yep and I was I was in training so
probably got those right around when I
got picked up for a commissioning
program so I'm just trying that time
frame like all the guys that I know from
Team 5 we're all there yeah well old
school 90s welcoming you aboard oh yeah
various great very gentle loving
environment yeah you know actually I
loved it now and I thought it would get
there of course and yet issued a pager
and then they'd give us all this awesome
gear and we'd be it you know the bar
drinking and all of a sudden they go off
like in the movies and we'd fly off and
you know save the princess and get back
in time for beers the next night and
then I get there it's like hey guy
they're cleaning that toilet and paint
that wall change those lightbulbs and I
was like Roger that let's do it I'm
gonna change I'm gonna be the best light
bulb changer or that letting you've got
here and so that was a little different
little did you go through sqt at Group
one or did you go through it second time
yeah it was the second class at Group
one okay and yes I went through that one
and it was good it was professionalizing
standardizing things obviously it's more
professional now but yeah it's great
time I love that I had a blast
maybe you rolled into person was your
what was your position in your first
Platoon what you do is the assistant
calm guy so for whatever reason they're
like college you're gonna calm school oh
yeah I want to point man
exactly you must be smart and say you
must have wanted to be a point man yeah
of course you read those books right
point man of course what patches Watson
that's what you wanted to watch in all
those movies so when they told me how's
me a comic I was like dang it you know
that's the guy that well wants they
gotta get shot first and all the Vietnam
movies right next to the agent
he's got a look at the antenna sticking
up in the jungle and over the grass and
that's where they so anyway but I did
that it was actually a great experience
being a calm guy because you're part of
the planning processes and your guy
and then you listen the radios yeah it
was great so it's going through that
calms coursing and bringing back the the
newest whenever newest radios new his
techniques whatever it is true the
platoon so even though you have a
primary calm guy you kind of know you
know what's going on after that that's a
good course there was anyway there was a
long course so it's good to be part of
the planning process so as for someone
was gonna be an officer at some point I
got to experience plan did you even have
that in your brain I knew it was an
option yeah it was an option so it was
either that or the other East Coast SEAL
team and you know wanted to do both of
those things I thought but I figured hey
let's give this a let's give this a look
it's check it out I'm brand new figure
this out and see if I'm gonna be officer
one day or go to another SEAL team or
move on and go to the you know Central
Intelligence Agency like all the people
that read about and watched in the
movies so and there's nothing going on
yes exactly nothing happening you know
some ship boardings like one platoon
diddle a ship boarding was it your
platoon no no it's because I did I did
some ship boarding very well I did him
ran for September 11th was this is
before that yes like free September 11th
doing shipboard sounds like you know I
was walking around like I was dim yeah
you know the like whoever I was walking
around like I was always gonna be a god
bad experience like no you're a loser
but back then that's what you wanted to
be doing no and to be quite frank and we
won't walk around like but we were I was
completely stoked that we got to do
something real then I got to lock and
load my gun like that it was cool and it
was good it was you know good enough
because most guys didn't get do that
most time you know many guys were just
going to ployment and they would train
other other you know foreign militaries
on how to do stuff and that's cool build
relationships with other countries cool
all that do some big exercises cool but
to actually lock and load your weapon
and get you have a real loadout was
pretty was like a big step back down and
it felt great for me but this was so
this is 97 and weird
going appointment that was a PACOM so is
this yeah whose it shipboard or no no
not know all the things you just talked
about mister training South Australia
wherever else are just done the normal
pay calm type thing well pre September
11th with not much going on and then you
come back from that deployment roll
right into another platoon because
that's what you guys do they become a
link one crews wonder you get promoted
to one crews wonder oh yeah we're either
primary comms guy or did you know stayed
out of comm so no how did you get any
good schools in between yep every fall
sniper oh yeah so the whole trouble yeah
yes a sniper is what I was so you
must've been squared away because they
don't just give those schools away I
mean I don't know you yes my chief but
yeah I was I did I checked with him he
was a crazy man that guy but yeah so
right to goodbye to Sniper school which
is what I wanted which I always wanted
to do so I so got there did with 73 days
I guess and what Kalinga are you gonna
Bali fever going on so uh we passed so I
passed but I didn't pass talking OH
because I didn't grow up doing that sort
of though so I was shooting you know
that was good
I grew up shooting so I didn't and no
problems there but then the stocking was
a was a shock to me yeah honey really
understand what was going I was crawling
before I was crawling for a thousand
meters you know how to do this and you
can just walk for most of that you know
I didn't know that at the time you know
those of us that didn't know we were
doing were just crawling an island in
the summer so I came back and did it
again and then knocked it out the second
is that Jason Gardner on and same thing
you you know he he said yeah shop fine
but failed stalking no no kiddin and and
then he came back on again and was
talking about well he talked about some
of the mistakes he made and it was very
similar to what you said but they would
tell him like hey figure out where
you're trying to get to and actually
analyze the situation before you start
moving and of course when he was younger
he was just new I'm just gonna go yeah
listen we get wet and he wouldn't make
it in time or people see him so yeah
that's talking thing is no joke out but
the second time was complete opposite
guys relaxed
thank you did you go did you when did
you go through it the second time when
would you go back for stalking
right before I think we deployed yeah
right before we deploy same time you do
it but there we got same work
oh okay that's cool that's awesome yeah
so right back but yeah I think I just
relaxed and I got there knocked them all
out had oh yeah if it get points for
people that don't know people the point
says you stock or whatever so the last I
think couple stocks I'd already had all
my points so I'm trying to help other
guys you know that's cool you know I
yeah looking back I'm like I should have
really helped these people or should
they have you know should I've gone back
to my sealed my buds thing like hit but
you different it's there to help them
like by trying to distract the
instructors or by finding that that Opie
begin to crawl and get within a certain
distance there and then let them know
hey no you're too far you're too close
risking yeah like oh there it is so he
didn't have to risk that sort of thing
so should I've done that maybe not but
anyway but it gave me a good practice to
because I get to push the limits then
which gave me a lot of confidence and
what I was going to do later that's
pretty awesome and then I paid for
myself to go to some some urban sniper
course at Pendleton some you know one of
these kind of fly-by-night operations
that was going on back then to teach
people how to do whatever someone to an
urban sniper of course that I paid for
because I was curious do that at the
time that's never school so I got to
learn about urban hides and all that
sort of thing which was pretty cool Reed
who's wrong I forget the name of it I
think it had like a cooler general were
they former I think former Marine
snipers I think that were a little
futher Pendleton I guess it probably
will had some connections there or
something exactly exactly so and then
the and three fault too and free fall
was a crazy one because that was um I
came back to the team one day and I
didn't even get free fall right away and
it Sniper school and then usually kinda
like one or the other for a new guy
coming back and so so my friends went
and I came back from and this was the
first time that they'd done the civilian
deal where they were training oh okay
but whoever that was and so came back
from lunch was like you're back and
you're kind of people going to schools
and it's you know some people they can
leave or whatever got married and so I
came back and I see a handy stump who
you know yeah and he's got this look on
his face I'm like that's weird I parked
my truck and you know there's no no gate
guard at the time he's drive onto base
remember that and he told us our one or
dear friends it had
burned in and died in free fall like in
that first week and that's like and then
of course what does the team do after a
night yeah I go to the family where you
know dear friends and do the whole all
that stuff is my first experience with
that and so as the team do oh you're
going to freefall yeah like a week later
after the funeral like hang okay let's
do it so so you haven't did the Yuma not
the civilian one but went to went to you
my stop to brag first for the for the
air tunnel that they have thing they
they did back then the window oh that's
good then and on to Yuma
so did those before my my second platoon
and then you go on your second you go in
your second deployment yeah yeah when
did you go on deployment so couple weeks
before September 11 through yeah so Guam
expecting a one like the first one just
day wearing the trains and people and
finally get to go to Thailand and you
have two weeks into it September 11th
happened people start banging on doors
up and down the barrack Sweden have TVs
in our room then so you know phones are
ringing because it's midnight I guess in
Guam and you know 9 a.m. on the East
Coast and we all get up and go down to
the basement of the barracks in Guam
where we had one TV and we all watched
the the Twin Towers fall on TV and I was
the Intel guy too so I was comms and
Intel and so I've been reading I just
read where the bin Laden book was that
previous year the man who declared war
on America who was called and so I was
doing I was always reading this stuff I
was always fascinated by it I was
reading about terrorism insurgencies
wanted to make myself the best seal I
could possibly be so I knew an al-qaeda
meant I knew it meant the base and so I
gave a a brief right away and nobody
knew remember the CEO of Guam had no
idea who al-qaeda was and so I gave my
brief and all of a sudden studied it
ever since but that was we thought we'd
be on planes the next day that this is
on let's go we start pallet size and
getting ready but really took a couple
weeks and then off we went and that's
when I did the ship warnings cuz we took
over for Team 3 who went into
Afghanistan and we ended up taking their
ship boarding mission which actually
looking back was a good one because
that's my only ship boarding experience
and it was interesting because it's like
a cop pulling over pulling over someone
in the other night you don't know what
you're walking up on no idea and instead
of a car and a cop this is a
class three tanker that's heading for
Iranian waters and you have a certain
amount of time to get on there and turn
it around and it was a t5 I'm turning
around a class three tanker using my GPS
and a compass turning this thing around
it was so it was pretty cool doing that
and there's some good coordination that
has to happen on those so it's as a calm
guy you're you're working a bunch of
different networks and yeah I mean
you're did you end up yeah well you just
said it you end up a lot of times being
the person that knows how to work GPS
cuz you're the calm guy at least it used
to be that way
in everybody that's all they know now
everybody knows how to do it but yeah
actually the map and compass that's I
went to later on jumping ahead I had to
relearn map and compass because I got so
dependent on GPS and it was a book I
think it's called be expert with map and
compass so when I took over the junior
officer training course before I got out
we had a really good math course that he
did and yes I mean Thomas of course the
map and compass exit so I was a calm guy
and when we first started getting issued
this is in like 92 we first started
getting issued the big GPS oh yeah they
were they were like the size of a and
they were big they got like the size of
two shoeboxes remember they were big the
PSN eight with this big giant antenna
that was like the size of my water
bottle but but what was interesting is
they they say okay Jocko you know you
gotta figure out how to work this thing
so I figured how to work it and though I
said well it all it does is tells us
where we are and they're like yeah and I
said if we have a compass we're good
like I know where we are on a map and
compass for sure I'm like I know Alice
II it's different you when you punch get
over the horizon but anyways so it was
kind of always surprising to me that
it's so much easier if you do a good
terrain study you can just walk and you
can look at your compass occasionally
and you know where you are rather than
constantly looking at a GPS and your
night vision trashed from that or
whatever you just just was a different
transition I mean and then obviously GPS
has became so good that yeah I mean
they're they're pretty awesome everyone
has on that watch yeah they're pretty
awesome now but I did like the map and
compass stuff because I grew up doing it
in the Sierras I grow up backpacking and
doin item but before I can't after
college I went to Alaska for three
months and backpack around up there
that a National Outdoor Leadership
School up there can once again training
getting ready we're so ready feds I went
to high school that's what I did then I
just do it doesn't matter you know it's
all the metal part doesn't matter how
much you prepare how little prepare it's
all if you want it if your average
athlete and you want this thing hey just
don't quit
you'll learn along the way you'll get in
better shape when you start running in
that sand just don't quit
that's it'll give you a good run in
shape so at what point did you put in
for an officer package
so that's spring before the September
11th deployment it was we had a let's
say a chief that was interesting a
leadership team I'd say that was
interesting and you know he five mafia
was not happy they were and it was one
of those things like hey I can complain
about it like everybody else or I can
put in this package and and go and do it
better than it was done for me so so
that's what I did then you got picked up
first time yeah oh you already had a
college degree yeah yeah so put it in
didn't but now forgot my remember
there's I won't say who he is cuz I
think he's an admiral now but he was an
XO at the time I went for my interview
there's a Friday afternoon so Friday
afternoon team five work out included a
keg and so you know I didn't I did the
work out but then I change into my
whites so now I mean my whites in the
spring and those things are horrible
I hate those uniforms but so I mean my
wife's getting them all perfect and I go
in to do my interview with the with the
XO at the time Admiral now and he's got
a beer in front of him his PG stuff it's
like I just want you to know how this is
gonna go and if it's any indication this
beer should be an indication of how this
interview is gonna go I was like I know
but I was still you know yeah of course
military bearing holes or the whole
thing but yeah of course they I didn't I
had a good first two platoons as a new
guy with no war going on and so I had
yeah I picked up the first time and then
you went to OCS oh yeah after I got back
so but of course timur xi happens and
I'm like dang it I made the wrong choice
say if where you want to be you want to
be in the list of guy
you know to be in the fight for a while
first anyway yeah so but it ended up
working out well because I got right
back from that deployment did well I did
a little training trip to to a place and
that was a great experience and then
classed up for OCS at in pensacola
pensacola and did the same thing yeah
did that too awful to do the same things
we did in boot camp folding underwear
folding t-shirts making our bed you know
all those things that somehow qualify
you to lead men in combat and then write
to the SEAL Teams right back to SEAL
Teams
and ended up with a great team that's uh
kind of written well the CEO had just
come back from another East Coast SEAL
team he spent almost a year deployed
after September 11th and wrought his
lessons learned back and then he sent me
into that team and right downrange
so as a brand new officer I was I was
downrange fairly quickly so timing wise
it worked out well for me that's that's
that's beautiful yeah I can learn it
learn a ton on that deployment and then
brought that back to my team and then
deployed again right right away to Iraq
so I got then you deployed as an
assistant commander I was sound like a
third way the third oh that's right
overdose yep third oh said you ended up
doing a lot of the admin stuff and you
still learn a lot but that's one was an
extra guy essentially that's when the
Joff happened so that's when I had
probably the most most formative time in
uniform was taking a sniper team image
off so it's pitch combat for he was a
two-week campaign so it was 11 days and
it was one of the first times I think
that that we really went to the
conventional side and said hey how can
we help yeah we're here to support you
in this campaign here's what I'm
bringing to the table these snipers
JTACs we can control aircraft for you
complete pre-planned air and and this is
this is what we can offer how can this
augment you how can this help and I'm
sure that's happened before but that was
the first time that that I was involved
in something like that and had a great
relationship Colonel Rainey was the guys
name you must be a general now or
retired probably retired now but I had a
great relationship with him and we just
got after it for 11 days out there was
great how many team you guys did you
ever with unit six I think and then we
had some polish ground guys and a MARSOC
DEP one because they were part of that
deployment with us was the
I guess trial run or yeah yeah no I saw
I those got turned over with me in
Baghdad yeah yeah because when you guys
got to Baghdad from your team yep
you went to Mosul yep first and I was
down to Baghdad doing a turnover with
the MARSOC guys - I knew a bunch of the
Marse archives from the old days of
doing shipboard 2.97 they're a bunch of
awesome yes awesome and then yeah and
then I went home and then I guess you
came down to Baghdad right before I went
home
take the PSD thing that mission and
while that was going on while we're
standing that thing up and I learned a
ton there - because you're like what are
we doing we're protecting the inner
Meraki government officials and we're
not turning over with anybody because it
hasn't been done before in the last guy
before now he just got blown up by an
IUD okay let's do this let's figure it
out and so I mean we were started with
one computer and my CEO from Team two
and it was I was at that computer just
like he'd be talking to me dictating
things and putting together the mission
bla bla bla and I was just learning and
you know chiming in right could 100
there when PSD got stood up
yeah one computer in one small office
and then it grew into this huge
monstrosity or should eventually became
but still learn a lot but that also
meant I was an extra extra dude is we
kind of figured out what was going on
and then I got to go up and help out
with MARSOC debt one cuz one of those
guys had to go back and do something so
I got to go up and help them out for a
little bit on the Intel side of the
house for a few weeks and while I was
there that's when the javac' tauf and
they're like we need snipers and so his
grab snipers and the roasting over yes
awesome scolson
yep I remember the the co team won so he
was attached to that MARSOC things
essentially working for Team wander at
the time and I remember him distinctly
calling me and was I was I was the Oh
and I was taking these guys to do this
thing that was kind of ambiguous we're
taking over a city as part of a bigger
campaign with through to seven calves
and he said hey whatever you do whatever
this means I don't really know what it
man eyes nodded but it's like whatever
you do don't go forward a friendly lines
and I was like okay like Roger supposing
me so within hours of being on the
ground we are pushing forward taking
pushing the enemy back going up getting
high ground
and calling in the Bradley's in a room
then coordinating all that stuff so
right away I'm disobeying his order and
and getting the job done because that's
what it that's what it took but it was
it was incredible to work with those
guys and we and it was a hodgepodge of
people wasn't just to seven calves it
was Army National Guard units it was air
from everywhere all coming together
working together for the first time and
making this thing happen and pushing the
enemy back towards the imam ali mosque
which is one of the holiest sites in all
of Islam and that 11th day we we had
that place all of them in the imam ali
mosque so we worked every day we'd push
forward a little bit and then go up take
the high ground everybody come up we'd
do that me to be there for a day though
the water would come up the food would
come up that army logistics train was
moving and then we push forward again
and it was incredible to be part of that
and you know help out where we could but
then of course we have them right where
we want them and ISM you know brand new
guys want to bomb it I want to drop a
bomb on that Imam Ali mosque looking
back you know they're probably not the
right decision they would not have no no
and but without honors in the whole
tactic all but not the best refugee no
no definitely now yeah in hindsight and
with what I've studied sense you know
bombing one of the holiest sites in all
of Islam probably was not for not having
the right move so that was that was
denied but if I Todd Hall solder was in
there although the Mahdi militia was in
there and then they did some sort of a
peace agreement ceasefire ish thing or
whatever and then we got to watch them
all leave and turn their weapons over to
the Iraqi National Guard or somebody and
that was the end of that so and then we
dealt with repercussions for Oh for a
while but there's good tactical
experience yeah because I got to come
back and talk about having you know
sniper weapon systems but also being
able to have a red dot on those things
to clear rooms because we were clearing
rooms and then using those same weapon
systems to set up and and do the job so
I've got to bring a lot of different
ways to make the who don't become
loopholes or whatever in the walls and
you know all that sort of thing so got
to bring back and share a lot of that
experience how much longer was
deployment once you got done with that I
think like a month or so ago so it was
kind of like a
yeah you're just like Stokes yeah it was
pretty good and yeah always that was a
formative experience and and then we say
they called it it wasn't the surge but
in the SEAL Teams we called it the surge
so we got to deploy okay year later
instead of a year and a half later it's
really all that man so I've got to get
right back after it so yeah because then
you came home yeah now did you get
platoon commander which are you so
analysis now I'm under second assistant
in my way up the second nominee awesome
that's great yeah it was amazing yeah
you're super stoked you're like whoa I
just had that awesome - pulling me up
and now I get to do another assistant
platoon commander for lunch no factor
and did this time you got to do an
actual work up or you did it work up the
first time - ish but I was that third Oh
so - an admin stuff here and there and
it wasn't quite the way it is today
where you're only doing admin stuff is
that kind of guy attached to the task
unit head shed over there but
essentially I was doing a ton of the end
but you're still doing all it uses of
the work oh yeah because the work CQC
you still when tomorrow you still went
to land warfare not all of them oh
really no because I would like to head
my deployment with these with the other
East Coast team in there I came back I
didn't like Haiti when that went down
because I was an extra guy so I got to
go down there which was pretty cool here
you make a good strap hanger oh yeah hey
one of those guys that kind of like yeah
I didn't always kind of like man I'm not
no yeah I'm not the second I'm not an
AOA seal Dave could be like a Berk a run
for his money
it was not a bad time to be just a dude
hanging out they could grab at any time
and of course I'm like can you go yep
yeah of course I can go ace we didn't
leave me in this afternoon
yes so you so now you're in you're now
you're doing an actual war Cup you get
to do all the training and then you go
on deployment and you go back to Iraq
again yep yep and he Ramadi this time
sweet so going into so now it so five so
five yep all about five and that's what
it wanted to be yeah of course the
changes throughout that work of your
going here you know in there whatever
but I forget at what time it turned -
you were going to Ramadi now
but that's where you that's what you
wanted to be you know 506 or and so we
got to get in there and you know is
interesting cuz I forget if there was
someone there before us or not I can't I
don't know why I can't remember if there
was a Turner there must've been somebody
there but I didn't stand out in my head
anyway I think it was a much smaller
debt before you got me me and I wasn't
part of that initial that first the head
shed goes over first
like the head shed went over and I was
the senior guy that came over with the
rest of the guys so I didn't really do
when I got when we got there most
everyone was gone and it was it was just
time to time to figure it out so we got
to do a few cool things like going out
with the Marines dressing up like a
Marine we're getting left behind to do
the snipers thoughts you know not
exactly what you guys did could you guys
really got after it but you know baby
steps
nerado so it was uh you know going just
going out with the Marines in the day
you know doing those patrols like where
this where the Haiti threat is high and
one of the most dangerous cities in the
world at the time like that was legit
yeah that's it get some evolution yeah
or just being on the basis I mean but
mortars coming in at night and I stayed
I didn't stay in that that whatever
though the building on the building yeah
I stayed out in the tents or the guys
yeah and yeah there's nothing there to
protect you from coming in like you just
sleep it and I want a little land on you
mortars suck yeah well on the receiving
end a yes and then you and then during
that deployment as well you also like to
Baghdad and work with an Indian's force
there - yep yep that's why I didn't see
you in turnover got to do this the
second thing in my time in the military
that was the most formative and we have
to go do some stuff in Baghdad with a 30
days basically yep yep doing that with a
more of a civilian type organization and
yeah with a little less I guess
oversight I'd say so I loved it this did
fit my personality and my my drive I
guess like I was a perfect fit for me at
that time actually one of the things
that happened during that time was the
inspiration for the the second book one
of the guys that I met there one of the
Iraqis that I was working with but yeah
that was that was a great time learned a
ton we're right there next to
guys from Great Britain other army guys
from there there I guess premiere
special operations unit so and we're
doing stuff together and we're training
together and the other guys had a really
good off tempo if I remember correctly
it was a good time to be part of that
yeah so I had a blast doing that learned
a ton and I got to stay active got to
that got to got to stay getting after it
everyone not every night but you know
yeah good good out tempo has a top tempo
and then you wrap up that deployment
which again these are these you got some
choice deployments I think it was yeah
choice deployments it was a good time to
work to be in my timing was good there
but then I get back so now I've done
five deployments in a row and you're
married I'm married yep got married
after that first deployment what's the
kid count at this point we are at one
okay one and then two for the next one
and then three for the next so what'd
you do when you got home from that
deployment to do with with when you got
done with your assistant platoon
commander tour so this is where my good
deal trained ants and I get back and now
I've done five deployments in a row but
if you count the enlisted ones three is
an officer all of them getting after it
and they're like you need to go
somewhere and get some professional
development oh yeah they did it's like
we call wind your scab yeah I would hope
on that there yep and set my XO had done
was the ops had been the OP so in
Germany so he's like you need to go to
Germany and you need to learn what a
unit does like you need to what like
that's the place to be in 1944 that's
where I want to be not in 2007 and so I
went kicking and screaming and I
probably should've just said Roger that
you know and but you know five
deployments in a row and those last
three being fairly intense I didn't with
my guys to go back without me you know I
felt like you know about banding them to
go to Germany and go like taste wine and
look at like castle walls and these
different towns like that no but you got
to go
but since I've worked with that other
government agency I got kind of I guess
you'd say recruited by them and while
I'm waiting to go to Germany I go up to
DC and do my bunch of
then they put you through up there and
get a class update to go to to that
organization and so I get to Germany I'm
there for a few months it's horrible I
hope they think the French language
school first because they thought I was
gonna go to North Africa West Africa how
long is French language school six
months six months no that was actually
good good but ever a good family time
all that stuff but I still wanted to be
alright I've got a straight up DOI and
straight up DL I'm on or a you helped me
out luckily I was at an off-site so I
don't have to go on base so that would
see that was good it so I was I guess I
guess good yep and of course now I find
out about CrossFit so I found about
CrossFit in Ramadi so now I'm just
crushing the CrossFit and people think
I'm insane because no one really had
seen that yet it's 2006-2007 and they're
like especially outside of the SEAL
Teams you're outside of you know
firefighters and all that stuff just the
regular gym basically you're doing all
the swinging barbells around like
they're kettlebell or whatever so some
get in shape I'm training for my next
whatever deployment trying to make
myself better but we go to Germany get
there hated a lot of people that were
loving it and that made me hate it even
more and I probably you know I probably
should have just said this is where the
government needs me so I'm gonna do the
best I can while I'm here and I did the
best I could but you're not doing
anything it was awful
I shouldn't say that it's a very
important place to be and they have a
mission here
that's great but it wasn't for me so I
dropped my papers to get out to go to
that because I was wanted to get back to
what I was doing in Iraq and Baghdad in
2006 getting it and to drop my papers
and gonna go just get out and go do that
and then a few weeks later they call me
the CEO called me back in and says hey
there's a oh I see at Team seven got out
there's a spot open do you want it and I
was not expecting that at all I said
whoa my mind was already set I was how
essentially mentally I was out I was
training I was getting ready for to go
back down right through this other group
and so on home talk to my wife she's
pregnant again with number her second
child and we decided to stay in am i
okay I can get get back after to do that
leadership role that that that I became
an officer to have and we like team
seven and that's where I met you right
so now I get my first taste of Jocko
some finally some actual professional
development that mattered and it's open
to that point as baptism by fire like
you show off a team - hey you're going
to Afghanistan oh no no training other
than the t-shirt folding and an
underwear folding at OCS luckily I had
some really good guys those deployments
that had already been to Afghanistan
that took me under their wing that you
know showed me how here's how these nods
work the point man only had them in your
last book tunes before September 11th
here's how you use these things yeah
that's kind of the way it used to be it
was OJT and the young junior officers or
even though young enlisted guys you just
get trained by the more experienced guys
and that works great if you're lucky
enough to have a good experienced guy
that has the desire to teach you that
really cares about the job that wants to
do a good job that recognizes the
importance of leadership and then it
works fun yep the problem is that's it's
not it doesn't always work like that you
get a guy that's a knucklehead you get a
guy doesn't care you just you can just
end up in a bad situation and then and
then some young kids we're young we're
influential what place we're very easily
influenced now and we see how a bad
leader acts and they tell us that that's
how we're supposed to act when we start
acting that way it's very nice I've seen
it happen many times you know it I'd
meet a guy it meet a guy that would be
coming through my training and like he
wouldn't quite be a good leader and I'd
you know I'd say to be talking to him
like oh who was your platoon chief when
you were a new guy and they've named a
guy and I'd say okay I see you know I
you could very easily find the root
problems here right or I'd get a young
oh I get a platoon commander and I'd say
well who is your you know who is your
platoon commander when you're in a OIC
and they'd give a name and they didn't I
would be a bad leader and he'd say okay
well I know where you got this from and
they would give me the ability to
actually steer him in the right
direction and say hey you know I
wouldn't be offensive about their old
boss or anything but I'd start like
saying hey there's another way to look
at these things
so yeah sure yeah that sounds like but
you got lucky you had some good
leadership I mean I know who your CEO
was a team - he's a frickin outstanding
yep and yeah so you had some good you
did some great mentorship yeah and he
care
about it he cared about my future and
his the senior guys he brought with him
from his other command also cared about
those senior Chiefs they cared about
what the next generation of both
enlisted and officers were gonna do and
how they were going to lead and so I was
very fortunate to be the recipient of
that mentorship and that guidance and
and that served me well and I had a good
foundation anyway but but but having
that have somebody that cared that put a
little structure by me not not know a
little structure behind it was it was
refreshing and yeah I just took all that
on board and just want to be the best
leader I could from for my guys but now
a team seven so that's now it's well we
won't it was a good it was a great
experience as an OIC
but most of that was due to the training
that you brought and so now I got to
professionalize things a little bit
think about them and now my deployment
my good deal train I thought ended and
in further it's spiked a little bit we
thought oh we're going back to
Afghanistan
yes it's gonna be you guys cuz you got
anybody thought it didn't end up being
my platoon so I got to go to the P I we
got to go to the Philippines and first
I'm like yeah that's a bummer but it
ended up being a great experience at an
outstation had more Special Forces guys
working for me than I had seals working
for me at multiple out stations that
that reported to me and and we were
there to you know assist
this is didn't buy his time thing yeah
but it was with a Philippine Marine
general and he'd been down there
fighting that insurgency in the southern
island chain since he was an instant or
whatever they you know a second
lieutenant there and you know so I took
the role of a student with him and
amazing guy and just I really learned
the area under what they were up against
learned how the enemy was adapting to
them and how it had changed over his
30-some years of doing that and of
course he was mentored because they've
been doing that for over 100 plus years
they've been fighting that thing so he
was a recipient of mentorship and
lessons from the people that came before
him and I took that time because I
noticed that the SF guys the army SF
guys particularly the Warrant Officer
that was there with me knew a lot more
about counterinsurgency than I did
like I had the tactical kick in the door
I had that experience but I didn't have
that broader piece yet and so I took
that time in the Philippines to study
and read a ton and who are the who are
the foremost experts on counter
insurgency out there where are they how
do I get in touch with them do they have
anything that can read and so I just
really schooled myself up and so it
became a kind of a competition between
me and him in discussions about
counterinsurgencies worldwide but
particularly where we are but how that
applies more broadly so I took it as a
time to and we did get to go to that got
to do some things down there the Filton
fill Marines with us just you know
helping with some more technical things
but but we they got to get after it and
they they lost guys and we were there
doing the the medevac and doing all that
sort of thing you know the bodies lined
up the whole deal and it was so was a it
was it ended up being a very I guess a
another formative experience for me and
then I got to use what I learned about
working with the Army once again but in
my Tech's deployment as a troop
commander once again I had I went back
to Iraq and had more SF guys working
under my command than then I had seals
mmm good we could run so you you went
through that work up when your opportun
commander in 2000 and mmm hey Tate yep
cool yeah so I was pretty settled in
because I had come home in 2006 and 2007
I took over the training so yeah we were
we were we were going hard oh yeah oh
yeah yeah my first experience I heard
all about this Jocko guy who's this guy
and and the first time that you walked
in to that room that briefing room at
Fort Knox of the stadium seating and
they have the diagram of things up for
the sand tables the front and you came
in and gave us this this talk and I was
like let's go get it but I had one of my
more formative experience in training in
that particular urban warfare
environment thing where I remember the
the scenario because you probably get it
for for most of the platoons and troops
coming through but you have a mission
and you go out there and you're doing
that mission and I'm the Ground Force
commander now
the GFC and I'm there in my my vehicle
and helicopter crashes like a few
buildings down a few blocks down and
that comes over the radio in for help
for a couple blocks away and we we still
guys in the building and our guys are
taking contact in the building and it's
all set up whatever and I'm like I'm
hearing that and I'm not going I'm going
to deal with this problem first went to
prioritize and execute yes but I wasn't
quite doing that yet I wasn't quite you
I'm listening to the radio and I'm
hearing they have a woman
the screaming a helicopter pilot female
screaming like they're surrounding us of
the whole thing you're like what do I do
aah and I split my force oh yeah I split
my force and so hey these two vehicles
breaking off you're gonna go to the
crash site secure the crash site well
then meet you at that crash site and
we'll exfil together so you know what
happens next
yes I do disaster disaster everything
goes fine that was the point of the
exercise I think if you split your force
that matter what happens every time but
but in this case it did who ends up at
being a disaster we get out wheelers
guys behind we have to go back in the
whole thing great it was great but I
remember sitting down with you afterward
and really drove home yeah prioritize
and execute and if you split your force
you better have a damn good reason just
what that force just had a guy named
John Stryker Meyer on the podcast the
last podcast you couldn't have heard it
yet because it's not out yet but he
settled a story he's in Vietnam and this
guy's just incredible sock just the most
insane stories ever and he's telling a
story and he goes yeah so I split my
forces and I put you know four guys on
one side the valley before guys in the
other side of the valley and we start
moving it and and I had to like find out
bro cuz I mean like this is this is
disturbing right and so I said hmm I was
like explain to me you know what what
made you decide to split your forces I
said I never liked it he goes I never he
goes I split on this what he said he
goes I split my forces two times in
Vietnam other than that it's a horrible
idea because I don't even like doing it
here I didn't have a choice
so that is a true statement that is a
true statement if you can avoid
splitting your forces avoid feeling
explain your forces
if you have to you better have a damn
good plan here but ever a damn good
reason because when then when you add
enemy fire into it trying to link up
forces friendly forces under enemy fire
I believe that's the hardest thing to do
in combat I think that's the hardest
thing to do in combat is separate forces
trying to link up with enemy contacts is
a freaking nightmare
yep and so if you can avoid it avoid it
yep you have had to do that in Baghdad
once with a QRF that we just talked to
on the radio before and asked that was a
little little dicey but but yeah that
not split your forces prioritizing
executing I'll never never forget that
never forget that experience and luckily
up until that point I hadn't been in a
situation where I had to do it downrange
because I probably would have done it
but after that training I was like I
would think I think long and hard yeah
maybe not long and hard I would think I
think it through before doing that work
so yeah tough move to make yeah that was
a great one but for me coming back from
Ramadi I was like super paranoid about
stuff and really into the fact that like
I wanted people did not make dumb
mistakes that I made or that I could
have made or that I saw other people
make like so I was pretty adamant to
make sure that guys were learning
lessons oh yeah no it was amazing that
journey was great and then we went to
Nylund of course into the Atlanta
warfare thing and I was very comfortable
with that because he died team on the
East Coast we've done that I am T
individual movement technique earlier on
I guess maybe then the West Coast so I
had it done it a couple times already so
some of my junior officers that had
never done it before and they were like
what are we doing what it's not just
just online and just the old school so
they didn't quite quite get it but I was
a platoon commander I was very
comfortable with that at Nilan so and it
was it was yeah obviously amazing
training specially when the technology
that uh that came along in the time
where there was no there was no hiding
from any mistakes that you might have
made out there you got the GPS on you
and you go back and you debrief it
there's none of that old school 90s like
no that wasn't me I think it was
so-and-so over there I would never do
something like that
oh no here it is here's your number
whatever it was on the errand and you
can watch it all in the debrief and
watch your little watch your little uh
your little what's that what's that
Titan or your little icon around ya
field and watch your little icon engage
your own force yeah oh yeah watch that
over over good right
yep no exactly and then going through
the second time you know things evolve
and change and all that but going
through the second time was a troop
commander then I was even more
comfortable with it particularly in
those those situations I knew the
lessons we wanted to get out of there
and then I could do it a little better
even than when I was a platoon commander
because I'd already learned some of
those in those particular scenarios but
yeah that was an amazing training and
there's no there's no question the the
impact that has had on the SEAL Teams
for them for them in a positive way
carried some down men did you okay that
was awesome yeah dad everybody
everyone's down and every yeah yeah a
lot of diamond drills Leah
it was a lot I mean especially and then
what was cool for me and people always
remember that but but well they talked
to me about it and and sometimes even
that you know this is too much you know
and the fact of the matter is if you if
your leadership did a good job inside of
a task unit or inside of a troop if the
leadership did a good job and the and
they use decentralized command and the
fireteam leaders got up and made things
happen and they kept things up like if
they did those things you couldn't we
the trade at guys the trade at cadre
couldn't take they couldn't they
couldn't put a bunch of people down
because they would get their asses
kicked by the troop the troop would
crush them and you know that one usually
not happen early on cuz they would have
to figure this out but once they got
good at it like the trade at guys would
say you know they'd be calling up myself
or the or the Master Chief running it
and be like hey can you bring me back to
life QB react life and be like no man
you you know you got killed of course
sometimes we would bring them back to
life to press the platoon harder of
course I'm up I'm not gonna claim that
we didn't do that damn we're gonna put
the pressure yeah yeah but uh that was
amazing the down man drills yeah I get
you get you in shape and then but then
it it gets people pissed off that guy
came back to life and you're pissed
they're not making good decisions and
you know and the other thing it's that
you talk
I passed on and they said I still think
about today and it gets in the book you
know take a breath look around or make a
call
SEC has that if I think about that
allowing I got to do is sit back get off
my gun look around what's going on
what's the sack tactical situation and
make a call yeah that's it so simple so
not easy so now they do but it's cool
when someone like like for someone like
yourself that's a sniper that likes to
shoot and all of a sudden your task me
to commander it's real easy to get to go
right back to what you're super
comfortable with which is hey let's get
on my gun and start killing bad guys but
you got forty other guys that are doing
that yep and none of those forty guys
are actually making a decision about
where you're gonna go next to save
everyone so you're the guy that has to
do it so that's you know that's a good
one yeah for sure when I look back in
old pictures I see that how my loadout
changed over the years and now by the
time I was a true commander you know my
I'm a lot lighter
well I'm radios now too long and my mags
I'm like I only feel free and one of the
gun or whatever it was but there's a
reason for that that's cuz that my job
is now to control this element and crush
the enemy not to be on the trigger and
then what was your was that deployment
like where'd you go as a to you so that
was interesting because it was the it
was the withdrawal from Iraq okay so
were there six months but it was because
we didn't know if we're staying if we
were going if we were staying or
authorities were gonna be where we were
going to be based there was a lot of
questions so we had to prepare both to
stay long-term and to get up back and
come home which is what ended up
happening so I think we got they've made
us our element actually ended up going
to the elite in at the end of November I
guess there was another month there but
it was again packing up and going home
essentially but you're working with a
partner force and you're using your
technical intelligence to try to
prosecute targets so that this it was
gonna become a highway of death on the
way out of there as the enemy just
that's did you drive out of there no he
flew guys for well no I was they drove
out pretty peacefully to yeah not a big
massive convoy I'll see you later
exactly there's not now what we expected
so but but it's cool for a little bit
because you got I think they they got a
little more liberal with some of the
targets there for a while when they're
like okay we don't want this highway
death that's not gonna be hungry because
I denied I didn't want to let a
unilateral hop go yeah when we're
leaving anyway yeah so so cut for a
little we got to do a couple offs but
but mostly it was a leadership challenge
to keep the guys focused on their
mission but at the same time getting
ready to go home for almost the entire
deployment so it was an interesting time
that was Basra southern Iraq Sidon been
down there before the Brits had been
there first of course or totally
different terrain than anything I hadn't
dealt with before and it was but it was
good it was an interesting deployment
how to create senior chief and who's
still in he's still in crushing it and
yeah came home and that was the last
time I'd ever tactically lead guys on
the battlefield and I knew that and
pretty much as soon as we were airborne
on the way home like getting out it so
that was it all yours were you out at
that point I think I was at sixteen
right there and what was your family
situation at this time so three kids and
right it's during the second work so so
in my OSC workup the one where I met you
and then went to the Philippines that's
when our middle child was born and we
found out I think it was at the month
checkup that something wasn't quite
right and he ended up well I'll get to
what he has but he couldn't didn't know
what was going on I wasn't eating wasn't
meeting milestones or something off and
my wife knew right away but I was just
like I just took just a gate when he's
hungry that sort of thing and we didn't
know what was happening so all during
that second of that deployment mean that
exceptional family member of category 5
reservist you know pretty severely
disabled and which means that you're not
going anywhere outside of your current
medical situation for your family so it
essentially takes the the decision out
of the service members hands which is a
good thing meaning you're gonna stay you
were in San Diego from you're staying so
that exceptional service member thing
says okay we got to take care of this
guy he's gonna stay in San Diego yep
yeah so that's said there's different
levels necessary your second during your
oh I see tour ordering you to you carry
you mean the TU commander tour the first
that we're still trying to figure out
what's going on
that first one in and nobody knew what
was going on with him so it splits a lot
of a lot of doctor visits all that sort
of thing but my wife did it all because
as you know when you're in that pendulum
has to be on the team that's your
responsibility as a leader you're you
owe it to the to the mission you owe it
to the guys you look to their families
you go to the country ultimately to have
that be your sole focus and that's how
it was the pendulum is over there
and my wife got that that's what that's
what you do as a leader obviously so
when I got back well yeah when I got
back we still don't know so now I've
done two work ups with this situation
two deployments with this situation my
wife's handled it the whole time
super-strong get back and I go to Budds
as the OP so so now I get to see people
ring the bell outside that office and
put the put the helmet down but in my
head I know I'm done and I evened up I
didn't make a I didn't hide it like I'll
hide it if they're planning on getting
out they won't say anything to anybody
in the chain of command cuz they might
stay in or whatever it is but I don't
like yep yeah now that's winning man
they're like no you're gonna be a next
up and out of 20 and it kind of
surprised people when I'd say that
because buzz is a machine that thing's
running and as an OP so it's fairly I
don't know it's not as dynamic let's say
is that a SEAL team and is driving that
well a little after that that someone
told Ross Perot our story the Ross Perot
and in Texas the guy and so about your
son yeah about our son cuz you still
didn't know what was going on right so
this is six years you bunch of different
hospitals and he's six years old
yeah no idea what's happening all sorts
of different diagnosis it was paid for
cedars-sinai going up there who we
thought were the foremost experts to an
oxygen my wife would take him to an
oxygen tank 30 days two hours a day or
whatever it was that we paid for just to
see if anything would would help someone
tells Ross Perot our story and this is
December of 2013 I want to say and I get
a call out of the blue from Ross Perot
who sounds exactly like Dana Carvey
impersonating Ross Perot in the 90s and
like what is going on
and he's like I'm gonna if we're gonna
fix your son like what
and he's like at once and send the jet
I'm gonna assemble a team of doctors
here in Texas and we're gonna fix him
and then he hangs up like what just
happened that was wild and about how her
later his lead doctor at Southwestern
Medical Center calls and says hey I know
mr. Perot has called you we're not gonna
send the jet tomorrow but we are gonna
send it and in the meantime send us
everything you have on your son any
medical records and we'll assemble a
team of genetic specialists here that
will take a look at everything and we'll
bring you guys in for some testing and
see what we can do Wow amazing so a
month later they send the jet g550 lands
and we get on and head off to Texas and
go to a week of testing in Dallas and
they send our blood all around the world
and found a genetic specialist in the
Netherlands who had just discovered the
certain genetic mutation that helps form
the brain at birth and that now it has a
name to it and it's the three doctors
that discovered this but when when we
found out about he was the 13th person
in the world
so number 13 in the world they found
with this and it was just called nr2 f1
which is the the gene that this mutation
affects and being able to put a name to
it for us especially for my wife that
was so liberating I can't really
describe what it means just to put a
name to it it seems like a simple thing
but not knowing for six years and then
being able to put a name to it and know
that a this is just one of those random
freaky things that happens and there's
nothing you could have done about it and
that's it just uh we got to put a name
to it so it was like Roger that okay now
what do we do and for us that's our
mission in life and he gave us purpose
and that purpose and mission is to make
sure that he reaches his full potential
whatever that may be
but he needs 24/7 full-time care for
life so and we have two kids bracketing
him on on either side so the real
challenge is raising those kids so that
their childhood is not solely defined by
the brothers condition and hopefully it
makes us all more loving more
compassionate people and so far it's
worked out that way but once again my
wife still bears the brunt of that every
day cuz I'm out here you know I'm having
a nice dinner last night I'm here
hanging out with you and she's at home
the only that sounds like
let's say I go on book tour and I go on
two weeks a book tour and you know I'm
shaking and all that she says she's got
it you know the the the wives that the
wives are incredible you know my
included she raised four kids and you
know I was barely ever around so and you
know the same thing with every guy that
we have on here that talks about what
their wives had to and I think Jason
Gardner when he was on he said he the
first time he was on he said put up with
his wife had to put up with lada and
then he came back on and said like he
didn't mean it like that
it's like actually had the strength to
handle hey just what the appropriate
statement is hey you know the wives the
the wives that stick around yeah which
isn't a big number right
most most women don't have the strength
just to get through this and deal with
this kind of thing but you know
obviously your wife is a saint and as
his mind and like okay you're gonna be
gone all the time
cool I got this I'm gonna handle it no
and that's how it has to be so now
hopefully the pendulum is not quite like
this you like I'm not dealing with life
and death situations so I can I can help
out a little more but I'm still yeah
there's an entrepreneurial type venture
writing is not just writing in a cave
somewhere and sending it off to New York
it's everything that goes along with
building a small business so right now
it's a it's a full-on sprint we have
momentum and I don't really have any
other speed besides just all in so
building this thing and but it's not
like you're deploying for six months
although things do shift now so now even
a like a two-week trip that that's like
a six month deployment
relatively now because it's not the
country asking you to do this you don't
you don't owe it to the guys or the
mission anymore
type thing but yeah I know I'm super
super fortunate to have the wife that I
do she's so strong and our son is so
he's 11 now and Berger has the mental
capacity of a two-year-old might say and
but with only so few people in the world
diagnosed with this I think now they're
probably up to must be in the 70s now
but you know I just every day is a every
day is still a struggle
but that's our mission you know we got
him for a reason and that's I look at it
as we got him because we're strong
enough to handle it and that's I don't
know how she'd have how else you do look
at it I don't really know
and then so as this is going on was that
one of the things that made you think
about getting out of the Navy oh yeah so
I didn't think about it while I was
doing that oh I see platoon or doing my
troop commander tour cuz I was just all
in but once I got back like when that
plane took off when we landed in San
Diego and I took a breath realize I'm
going to buds I see people guys running
on the beach you know doing that doing
the buds thing that's not why I came in
I came in to do the job I'd done the job
now I owe it to my family to uh to let
that pendulum go back and take care of
them so it was very obvious to me it
wasn't like it wasn't it wasn't
something I struggled with I think a lot
of guys like should I get to stay here
should I get out what's my hard time
with that transition mine was not
difficult neither was the decision to
get out because I was handed my next
mission really we just didn't care of
the family and especially our middle
child so in that respect my transition
easy is the wrong word but I knew what I
needed the decision was clear yep there
was no no wavering and then you knew
from your previous from your childhood
that the job you were gonna take the job
you're gonna go after after you retired
was gonna be a writer yep yep and of
course you can't say that especially at
that time and the SEAL Teams later you
know the min Laden stuff is going on and
all that so that's when I played very
close to the chest I say to the best so
I knew what I wanted to do my whole life
I didn't think about it wasn't the team
it was just like that's what I'm gonna
do next there that's the amount of
thought I put into writing when I was in
the teams but everything that I read
growing up was part of that education
all the reading nonfiction that I did on
insurgencies and terrorism all that fed
into it and all the personal experience
downrange so it's almost like I could
not be more prepared for what I'm doing
now as a writer but I didn't during
those last couple years I was just like
okay op so at Budds then to junior
officer training course oh I see which
was grape is only for a couple months
but I love that because you get to pass
on some lessons or some and and don't
move on out but last year in the Navy
and I think I've heard you talk about
this before and that you didn't do all
these things that you're supposed to do
when you get out there I had wanted to
what are the taps whatever that course
it was awful
I could did all those things that you're
supposed to be saying I'm like you could
how did you get out of that yeah well no
one's gonna tell you what's I mean
you're big dude you're no one's gonna
tell you gotta do this but I when I did
that course and I went to medical and I
went to dental and I did all the
signatures and I got my paperwork in
order and that was like the whole last
year spine surgery had spine surgery and
our last year yeah so that was good and
so got a lot taken taken care of but
it's during that time where I'm like
okay my jobs to get out of the Navy now
well now I'm I started thinking about
this writing thing and that's when I
wrote down about seven different ideas I
put him on the table in front of me like
one-page synopsis type things and I
chose the one that I thought would
resonate with people the most and that's
that that theme of revenge because
that's that resonated with me as a kid
growing up both in movies and books and
it's something that just resonates with
people in general is that theme for
whatever reason so I knew the first book
would be when that would be the theme of
the first novel and then when did you
start actually writing it during that
last year so yeah outline synopsis
started writing title came really
quickly all that sort of thing but then
submitted it so I got out summer of 2016
was my retirement and submitted it to
Simon & Schuster in the fall of 2016 and
I got very lucky I'm very very lucky and
that's a friend calls me out of the blue
and he says hey you know this author
Brad Thor I said oh yeah of course I
know him and he said well I know you're
writing this book do you want to talk to
him maybe have some advice for you
I said plea talk to me and so let me set
it up yeah it's a former CEO who's out
in the finance world now and they sat
next to each other at some fundraiser or
something
and so I get on the phone with this door
guy and he could not have been more
generous with this time it's kind like
an interview it's kind of like a why do
you want to write type thing that was
the underlying kind of theme of our
conversation and I think he wanted to
make sure I was doing it for the right
reasons and yeah I told him the truth
about my mom being a librarian reading
all this stuff growing up and all these
authors I loved and wanting to do this
forever he's like alright I'm not gonna
help you as you go along so don't send
me chapters don't ask me questions but
if you write a book if you finish a book
I will let Simon issues to know that
it's coming can't guarantee they'll open
it definitely can't guarantee that
they'll like it if they read it but as a
thank-you your friend told me some of
the things you did in the teams and as a
thank you for that I will let them know
it's coming and I'm like Roger that he
said well you're gonna be done I said
one year from today and call them back
one year to the day later and as I hate
to remember me and he sure did and I
said it's done and he said well is it
done
I says the best it can possibly be I was
like well nope no I can still work on it
a little more but it's done
he said well call me back when it's the
best that it can possibly be
and I said Roger that such of another
four months of reading editing rewriting
getting it to you know if you held on to
it for ten years you could probably make
it better by degree but I mean it was at
that stage where was ready for another
set eyes and called them back four
months later and he said okay I'll let
my editor know what's coming and shipped
it off and she read it next thing you
know I'm gonna plane to New York and
we're having coffee and thank you want
to make sure I wasn't a crazy person and
she said hey I want this thing but but
you need an agent and I'm like why do
you get one of those and especially
introduced me to four agents and then I
uh I chose one next thing you know we're
off to the races so I got very lucky
yeah that's that's that's awesome it
does take a little bit of luck how do
you how do you actually mechanically
write like what do you actually do yep
so all those seven different synopsis
that I had ahead of time where I picked
the one now all those other ones are
turning in to these next novels even
though I might have different characters
or whatever acting more for those ones
so I have about seven different novels
in the pipe ready to go so start with
that that idea listen ops is like a one
page or two pager
an outline and then as I write I fill in
that outline because new things the new
ideas come up new chapters new
characters and I added to that outline
so then it was in word up until very
recently and I so I have a visual
representation what's what you switch to
from Word to Scribner okay we shall get
to here in a second game change so yeah
in words you're scrolling copying and
pasting moving chapters around and then
I don't want to cut and then have it
disappear because they're nervous as it
backed up oh my god
so so yeah so I have none of that
Perrigo yeah exactly
don't cut and paste that moment's out
something I hit the wrong thing and it's
gone
so yeah I fill in that outline till I'd
say about 75% and then it becomes not as
efficient for me to continue to just
have an outline that's now very complete
now I can just transition to just the
story about that point but you know
recently I found out about this thing
Scrivener and that it set up very much
like word but you it's broken down by
chapter so you can drag and drop
chapters and see how it looks you can
have each one of those chapters have a
synopsis so it shows up as essentially
like a card or a yellow sticky and
you're looking at this whole thing and
they go you know what chapter six should
really be chapter three drag and drop
and you can move in research so you can
drag in articles from online pictures
video into research folders so it's all
right there instead of like what file
was that did I copy you are like a day
late and eight bucks too late for me at
this point seriously like that sounds
like brilliant yeah and I could so use
that and I just finished my eighth book
nice so that sucks
yeah that sounds awesome for nine yeah
yeah a nine yeah which I started
yesterday yep and you can import from
Word so I had about half of those oh
yeah it's you import from Word and it
breaks it into chapters you just put an
icon and let it know whatever that
little symbol is where you want the
chapter breaks and then can you export
it back to work and I haven't done that
yet so I will be doing that in the next
couple weeks for book three
have not actually have imported from
word I've not exported so what you can
say you can yep they say you can in the
tutorial video and they show you how but
I have not had done that check yeah yeah
I'm all over it can I ever liked it word
so before we nerd out too hard we'll
move on to something else yeah so you
get done with these and and where did
you I mean what did you do with your
family once you retire because you have
the mission of your kid yep and your
kids mm-hmm you had the mission now that
you got to finish this book did you
finish that book while you're still
active duty nope nope sell finished it
just a formless afterwards so you set
yourself up financially somewhat that
you were in a survivable scenario even
without alternate income besides your
retirement I had other businesses you
had some other little you had some other
little side things going on yeah give
you enough money to float this gig yep I
have an operation in Hawaii
the hunting operation out there with a
couple of the partners every so often
someone would ask me to do some speaking
or whatever that sort of thing did some
some tactical training little things
like that but job was I was set up to to
be able to move into this financially
and then where did you where'd you move
to so we got out and we weren't planning
on moving because our son we thought hey
we have this the support network built
up now over the last six seven years
it's here in San Diego and we can never
move we can't we definitely can't go
someplace where it's cold because he
just lies down and just anyway it would
be very difficult to take him to a place
where it was rainy or snowy we had to
put extra clothes on him like that sort
of thing and then we go to Park City
Utah the the winter after I get out and
we took our son on vacation with us for
the first time and we started going to
Park City during my last couple years
when I'm not so I built up tunnel leave
I never took leave until those last
couple years because last couple of
years I'm like well I'm not taking guys
downrange anymore let's start taking
some leave we have all this on the books
so we would go to Park City with a few
friends from San Diego because it's
easier to fly to Salt Lake and drive to
Park City and it was to drive through
bands of traffic to get to Mammoth or
Big Bear or whatever else so some
started doing that last couple years and
then we took our son on vacation with us
and we took someone with us to help so
we had an extra set of hands but we got
there and we spent two weeks in Park
City and we thought you know what we can
do this we're not tied to San Diego we
brought someone yes that was your fault
I'm yes but we did it and that was like
ah that opened just a few doors for us
and that we didn't think we're open to
us ever and while we were there I opened
this open this magazine and say this is
his house around the corner here let's
go check this thing out so we drove
around the corner checked it out I'm
like let's move we decided to write Penn
in there to move and got the house and
six months later were there and I think
it helped to make a physical and
psychological break with the military
for me because I was in Coronado and as
the Apso of buds I saw so many guys they
couldn't let it go and obviously it's a
huge part of who I am it's in my mid my
novels and all that stuff is a huge part
of me but I saw guys that kept coming
back to buzz kept calling me as the OP
so he can I get a tour I want to show
somebody around no problem come on in
and you know all about it but I saw
these couldn't let it go going to all
the charity events going to the same
bars going to the same grocery stores
especially in Coronado yeah so I think
for me it was healthy to say that was
one chapter in my life obviously a huge
influence on me I wanted to do it my
whole life but now now we're moving
forward and now there's a new chapter
and that's as an author and that's
taking care of my family and raising our
kids to be good citizens and good people
and that's what I'm gonna do next I
think it just helped to not run into
somebody at the grocery store from a
platoon
how are you doing Oh who's your Co
what's uh you know and all those sorts
the same questions that just keeps that
tie so being able to say goodbye to San
Diego know who's saying it was great to
us love San Diego I love Coronado but
that was one part of our life her new
life is in the mountains raising our
kids in a ski town and you're super
stoked right now on that yeah yeah love
it over there loving up there and we got
there we drove you know we put a u-haul
and we drove through the night and all
that and we get there you have 13 hours
later because you're chugging along with
this u-haul and we get to unload it the
next day we go to the grocery store and
we look around and we're like and people
in Park City are in good shape
like we thought we were in pretty good
shape in San Diego like these people are
insane in Park City it just draws these
people that want to raise their kids in
ski towns usually they've done something
somewhere else where they you know hate
their know whatever they they can live
there yeah and they're really in to
being in shape and being the best people
physically mentally spiritually whatever
just being the best most efficient
people they can be and luckily I had
some friends up there already and it's
insane group of guys that works out in
the morning we wake up at 5:00 and once
again that pendulum this last few months
has been on the writing but when I first
got there I start working out with these
guys that I knew from before and Hopi
darling is kind of the the leader that
used to be the CEO of Skull Candy and
ICO he has a bunch of other ventures but
this guy is in insane shape and he's
there every morning at 5:30 with some
crazy workout like picture your hardest
CrossFit workout and then times it by
three or four had some trail running
it's crazy
and so I showed up with these guys and
they're awesome but they're all about
just human potential I think is the best
way to put it and maximizing that
potential whether it's your family
whether it's in business personally
whatever just and and staying up to date
on the latest and the greatest and
testing things out and they're an
amazing group of people so I'm very
fortunate to get to work out and spend
time with them it's all high performers
we all push each other and even though
I'm not the not the fastest anymore
certainly not the strongest especially
with this crew it's it's cool to get out
there and and then just be you know just
be together like a little team awesome
well I mean it looks like we're pretty
good
that's that gets us to today you know
where you're at
probably a good place to wrap the books
tell us just a little bit about the
books what do we need to know about book
1 book 2 yeah
so the first one is the terminal list
which I didn't say it out loud for about
it for the first year I was working on
it and I said it out loud for the first
time there's two L's next to each other
and I said it for the first time I was
like dang it like it's a tough one to
say the terminal list but in its base
level that is a story of revenge without
constraint and that's what I wanted to
explore
I think was I adored a team five opps
1997 I saw he had somebody xeroxed
copied a thing from the brand-new
internet that had a picture of a samurai
on it it said something about a samurai
going into battle thinking they were
already dead and you know I went back
and looked at on my own but Sciuto books
from high school and college and I
thought oh they did that because they
thought it made a more effective and
efficient lawyers they're going into
battle already dead I thought how do you
do that with a modern warrior how do you
do that with someone that has a
background similar to mine so I can
explore these feelings and emotions
behind different experiences that I had
downrange and a completely fictional
sense I don't make him already dead and
then I thought about the church hearings
in the late 70s and how the government
had tested certain drugs on our nation
soldiers on mental patient mental mental
institutions college students without a
any review any sort of structure in
place with how that's can I going to go
down and things changed after that and I
thought well what if somebody didn't get
that memo but if there was something
they wanted to test out they wanted to
test it out on some of our nation's most
elite soldiers and then something goes
wrong so how do i free this guy up to
think he's already dead and they come
back and have to use the tactics
techniques and procedures of the enemy
on home soil so essentially I wanted
someone that thought they were already
dead that now gets to bring what was so
effective against us in Iraq and
Afghanistan to home soil as he works his
way of a list putting the bad guys in
the ground one by one so that's that's
really what the first ones about and
then I mean if you dig a little deeper
into it more like psychological wise I
guess it's about a veteran that comes
home and brings the wars from Iraq and
Afghanistan home to people that have
been sending young men and women to
their deaths for clothes well coming up
on 20 years now pretty soon so can you
read it like that too but that's that's
deep that's deep dark in the words you
pick up with true believer so it's that
continuation of the story so in high
school I saw it's a it was on PBS
a special with bill moyers he had an
interview with a guy named joseph
campbell who wrote a book called the
power of myth and the hero with a
thousand faces and i was fascinated by
it because well i already learned to
write one day and i member they talked
about george lucas being influenced by
this for Star Wars and the samurai
aspect of different things and then how
across culture the hero's journey is
similar very similar for the cultures
that had never touched each other before
yeah China Native American Indian Africa
Northern Europe they all had this
similar journey and usually it's a
reluctant hero that goes on a journey
emerges transformed at the end of that
journey so that was a big influence so
in writing these you have to call Mikey
in the dragon's eye just reading that's
my kid the other night and yeah so he so
he has to go what you gotta go into the
cave and you have to emerge transformed
but how do you do that with one book and
how do you make that overarching a
series as well so there's two things I
think about as I'm writing I think about
that hero's journey in the context of
one singular story and then over what I
hope will be a long-term series so
that's what I'm what I'm thinking about
as I write these things and then true
believers the continuation of that story
but it was inspired by somebody I met in
Iraq in 2006 and I thought what if I
made this interaction and what I heard
through the grapevine later what if I
made this a lot more interesting and
fictionalized it and so that's where
though the second one picks up and it's
really a story of redemption and taking
the was still taking the emotions and
the feelings behind certain things that
happened downrange but also now
exploring what that transition was like
because the earlier in the story James
Reese has to go through a transformative
journey and the second was all about
Redemption and when is windows book 2
winds true believer come out July 30th
July 30 out that comes out in terminal
list is out right now it is out yeah a
second one should have come out April
2nd but the Department of Defense took
seven months to do a 30 day a review
someone to make sure I was honoring my
former security clearances by submitting
it to the Department of Defense you just
leave the stuff that they tell you to
take out or their stuff that they tell
you to redact you just you just black it
out just black it out they know if I
write around it and my still
you did that in true in the terminal
list - yeah when he said it to me I you
gave me heads up you said he had just
blacked things out and you know
obviously my books have been well not my
kids books but my other books have been
through the Pentagon review and they
tell you that could remove certain
things and we would remove it and change
it so it's acceptable to them but you
just blacked it out just left it blacked
out yeah I was worried like well if I
write around this and then I publish it
and then come back and say oh you didn't
quite why right around that enough I do
that just to be cool kind of and it also
has a lot of entities with the marketing
ya know and it's like I mean I was I was
looking through it and looking at like
what and I can I can figure out a lot of
them I go oh they didn't want them to
say that oh they don't want to say that
so it's pretty cool but you can still I
mean obviously you can still understand
all the context around it you just don't
know a certain like specific term or a
certain specific location or a certain
specific name but yeah that's pretty
that's pretty cool yeah cool that you
left it in there and the books are
available everywhere everywhere yeah
every audio people love the audio Ray
Porter does the audio he's an awesome to
his upper audio book of the year this
year so we're in New York and it's up
there well I texted you because you
wrote you know you're in you're in your
category yeah so I was texting you I
took a picture of the screen and
everything whose coolest ended up there
knows a Stephen King like I was like
that was pretty cool that's pretty cool
you to find you
you got your website which is official
Jack car.com
that's it because you didn't buy the URL
Jack car earlier I think an insurance
guy has it in the Oscars but guys
holding it for hostage and we're gonna
get it ya know maybe you will never say
never yeah so that's yeah that's a and
that's one that people want to geek out
a little more on the weapons the knives
that sort of thing
the website go deep dives into a lot
more of that stuff in the books cuz you
get your nerd on yeah you get your
weapons now you would exactly like you
bring the librarian of your mom the to
the the damn jack car weapons scene
that's it that's it so it's on there and
and then on the socials which I am very
new to I'm about a year and a half into
this now is Jack car USA you're on the
socials and
is a Facebook but three was just too
much like so somebody else just copies
and paste things from there into there
but on Instagram and Twitter Jack are
USA and those are the ones why interact
with you interacting in the game that's
it
I'm in on those but three is just too
daunting just good I knew it nope nope
its next level I'm crazy like that
that's how its super motivated I have I
got three social media platforms kill me
now
and what you know usually I have a every
now I got have a hard time going to
sleep putting my mind's racing I'm
thinking about all these things thinking
about storylines solving problems on the
written page here aggressively like I
used to do on the battlefield but
usually I don't have a problem staying
asleep once I get there this morning of
307 am and I'm like dang and I took a
picture of it for you so I'm like dang
did you post it no no it's d-day today
so I didn't think that would I get my
d-day post on point no but I will I will
post it d-day
awesome yeah so I think that's a good
place to wrap yo echo mm-hmm Jack was
just talking about Fitness she's talking
about being prepared yeah opened up
talking about being a true believer that
knows the cause yeah fully you know what
do you know about you know sort of that
cause being on the path you're leaving
in it truly yeah fully I do want to
comment on how you blacked out the the
classified parts of your book it's kind
of like in the movies right or when they
wanna you know they show movies on HBO
or in the cinema whatever it's all good
they put it on USA or one of these you
know networks they gotta edit it right
edited for television so there's three
ways they do it in the movies they
either just take out the whole scene
which is like what they do with books
right sometimes like I guess they could
yeah you usually change it yes we do
that movies too in the movie yeah they
have a dubbed voice over for the
swearing yeah right and every once in a
while you have a movie with an actual
different scene yeah if you watch
Trading Places or something I mean they
have actual different scenes like she
that they redid sure then the third is
the blackout version what you did which
they just blank it out so if there's
he'll be like what the and the mouth
will show it but they just won't have
the audio right to me that's the best
way to do it
because it keeps you in the story you're
like okay he swore right there I get it
you can't swear on teeth on this network
or whatever but in my opinion this the
blackout the physical like I just saw it
in there it's physically blacked out
you know anti highlighted low lighted
yeah a few it gives it the mystique yeah
kind of like there's something hidden
under here that's classified they can't
know so classified yeah no but you can't
even know about it
yeah even even that it's fiction which
is even like half level up even from
yeah yeah that's like wait a second
there redacting fiction yeah when he
said like secret cuz you and I both know
what gets redacted ridiculous and it's
not I know I don't have build it up too
much so we're gonna talk about what a
major hero was we'll edit this out my
two the first one I didn't I didn't
appeal so you have a year to appeal
these things and I didn't do it a
personal cuz I didn't have any enough
money so a second one though they took
kind a lot more in this second one and
I'm appealing this one so and what you
do for the appeal is you find the
information on government websites you
can't just go to Wikipedia whatever else
okay but on actual government websites
in congressional testimony out there via
the government so repealing this one and
almost everything in there except for
one little phrase we found it on
government websites so we're appealing
so that if the paperback comes out in
this now you can see what the government
didn't want you to see but it's I don't
want to build it up too much cuz it's
really yeah it's not as cool as it
sounds no but one thing that they took
out was so surprising as I made up so I
made up a location because I'd been
there yeah before I came into one in the
military so I used it as a location in
the novel because it made sense where
it's tower second one's kind of starts
in Africa and then it goes up here and
you know goes into whatever but I'm like
that's a big good place for kind of the
cave gotta go there change got
transformed
and so ice made it up I'd been there I
could describe the rocks I could
describe the mountains I can describe
the architecture so I put it in there
they blacked it all out
it's totally made up they blacked it all
out but they left in by accident the the
capital of that country so I blacked it
out for them nobody knowing in their
intent I took it out for what they
missed that they took out the type of
architecture they took out the mountains
they took out any reference to the
country which is so strange but they
left in by accident at the Capitol I
know what that grows right yeah exactly
what else was up in that cave formation
this is stranger than fiction yeah but
that's good that's another selling point
in a way when you can say this like I'm
revealing in this book what the
government didn't want you to say yeah
actually you know exactly so the
paperback yeah yeah we'll see how it
goes
cool man well one day what did you
revisit jujitsu or what so take heavies
right now I know I know so I dabbled
through the years but essentially what I
did up until 95 that's really my base
and I got a obviously shooting well not
obviously so I'm shoot all the time stay
in shape that sort of thing but that
jujitsu is wherever I am right now that
is where my martial ground fighting
skills are going to remain where why are
you committing to that right yeah the
spine surgery oh yeah - just time wise
and knowing where my focus needs to be
right now
simple things what do you think's worse
for your spine clean and jerks or
grappling cleaning jerks I'm gonna have
to agree I'm not love I don't I don't
actually think cleaner jerks are bad for
your spine I think they're good for your
spine but groundless a few actually
that's the this is the delve into how
you get your information for your little
books right oh yeah you sent me a text
or whatever it a two years ago hey if a
guy was in Virginia one to train with
like the best on the East Coast where
would he go and train yep you sent me
that text I'm like send him to his own
grave there it is you got right back in
the operation
and it went right in the book these guys
used research you've ever done I was
great that's Jocko perfect yup and it
made it right in the book and I moved on
oh I feel bad when people text me that
don't text them back like right away oh
really so you must feel real bad with me
oh yeah all right away stay real foreign
I can but sometimes it just doesn't like
give you a lot of texts and like you got
to sit there and you know but I try and
text people back eventually or you might
need to hit me with a little father mind
or you'll follow up yeah well hey um
well doing jujitsu and peaking at 95
staying there is better than not
thinking you do to enough people the
kids were in it yeah right away daughter
in it from maybe four oh just saying the
game right now so now that we need to
talk yeah so she's into snowboarding now
in tennis so she turned 13 that's cool
there really but I think age 11 or maybe
twice 11 I think you might have stopped
she kind of yeah
it stopped that was definite yeah is
there jujitsu in Park City I know
there's full-on jujitsu in Utah you got
Pedro soured up there you got all kinds
of good jiu-jitsu people up in Salt Lake
City yeah for sure
yep no we sure do and there's one I
think Pedro Sauer has I think a and a
little off site in Park City memory lead
so of course we checked it out before
the move they move sense so I haven't
followed where they moved to but I think
there's one still there but it was
important to me because at the time we
moved my daughter was still and it our
little guy was in it our eight year old
now eight year old so it was important
to me that there was jiu-jitsu where we
were moving and but now that we moved I
would get there and it's gone it's just
an empty space so I think it's still
there somewhere but the kids you know
they're doing their things unfortunately
you know there's a lot to do a lot to do
up there but we know I dabbled over over
the years we're still doing it was an OP
so or nx-os but before I got out in
Coronado cuz it was right there I go at
lunch and roll with some guys I'll do
some research
I'll figure out where we can get you get
you and your family back in the game up
and so up in Park City because I I
personally feel like guilty to have your
family not training to have you not
training me do
that's great I know you're taking some
extreme ownership their car you're
taking some extreme aversion for that
recently getting in the game yeah in the
stories you mean you know yeah the
fictionalized yeah James Reese is on
yeah but you gotta get you know you talk
about transferring those emotions right
yeah real world
I remember how never Laurie was like to
get you know just just thrown around the
mat more white yeah yeah I was worried
that's why I didn't tell you I was
coming in last night I didn't I was
worried that I'd be up at 3:00 something
getting just destroyed on the mast yeah
he is out so you know that needs rapidly
yeah approach him yeah it's been for
long status all good and we're gonna
look forward to that
so back you just do when you get back
and you GT gonna need a key
or if you're getting them to jiu-jitsu
for the first time you're gonna need a
gate Doogie no key do both that's the
best hundred-percent anyway so what's
the if here at Park City Utah if you get
in a fight in Park City Utah the other
person is almost guaranteed to be
wearing a game out yeah right that's
true huh straight-up wearing a jacket
good point you said we're always called
up we're in a North Faces Park right
just Patagonia boom it's very possible
I'm not gonna bail on a Patagonia jacket
yeah let's get some of that famously
what's the Patagonia jacket this is the
jacket it's like a parka this is another
I'd explain through what a parka was on
one podcast Wow
he's from Hawaii Wow nonetheless some
nice sounds good
uh similar to Aggie top good alright
we're gonna do you what kind of ghee
we're gonna get do you know I know that
urgentiy 100% there's only one that's
what in the world why would you not get
the best one in the oil
there's no reason percent get the best
one in the oil is it is it because the
best one costs five times more than the
not best one No
or is that all kiss the same no same
same cost well you can choose you can
grab the the big get lakhs
what do you call what's the word you
always do use not always before you
luxurious a lug nut Reyes unless you can
grab down if you want good good up to
you origin either various uh what do you
call like options of keys
call me in America by the way speaking
of made in America you know other
clothes made in America
mm-hmm namely t-shirts yeah sure
but also sweatshirts yeah and also
newest latest jeans which I have someone
the way by the way finally be little we
teamed up we ended up we're the link but
we're in a secondary group mean belittle
mmm Brian Littlefield um and you know
we're we're tight we're in the game
whatever right but we're always last to
get the cool new stuff choco always
first Pete always first right us always
we're not even second we're not even
third were last every time unless we
banded together and now I have a paired
origin jeans made in America American
denim jeans on the way to me so please
happy to announce Talon to everyone also
rash guard the first other judicious
stuff so also some supplements mm-hmm
the most important kind of supplements
boom joints keep you in the game protein
keep you in the game the white tea is
jakka white tier supplement yes yeah
because it has to be a supplement cuz
what else would give you about eight
thousand pounds oh nothing and it's
certified organic so the whole water
thing no how'd you like your first
chocolate whitey I couldn't do the
podcast without having one those people
some people don't it's not sweet you
know there's no sugar in there nope it's
just tea it's great but it tastes but it
has the pomegranate little fruitiness to
it thank you one more yeah if you want
more no I'm a big fan big fan enough to
you know you should give somebody a lift
and then go right cuz whenever I
whenever I right that's guarantee that's
guaranteed like at least 300 words
coming or coming out to you live boozy
smooth just like it I like it into the
computer got my marching orders
I'm also disciplined by the way speaking
of writing
oh that's a good one I found and I don't
write as much is you you might not have
known that but
you know but I make these videos every
once a while if you're on the dis video
czar awesome even that kind of comes a
lot easier oh yeah when you're doing a
favorite one we lie to ourselves oh yeah
yeah that is a good one that is a good
one yeah your representation yeah yeah
can't grow otherwise it's true it's
absolutely true oh yeah this one that's
a good one and discipling go if you
don't want to you know mix it up and do
all that stuff if you're on the go
essentially right that's how it goes did
somebody make sense you just go you get
more which is additional protein yeah
for your life cuz we all know we're
eating steak they're eating chicken some
people are eating sushi yes we are a lot
of that all gives you protein which is
good sometimes you need a little bit
more or sometimes you just want it it's
a dessert dessert straight up
have you tried the I have not yet so
looking forward to it I'll just just
it's ridiculous you ever had a Nestle
strawberry Quik yes it's been a long
time did you like it I was yes I like a
chocolate one I think okay you like to
start yeah some people are like that
never tried them both but I go back to
the chocolate yeah this strawberry
Slayer Molk tastes absolutely delicious
I mean we have warrior kid milk so
frankly that's yeah yep it's totally
good to go I keep meeting to get that
too because our kids man they do not
anyway yes your kids want to eat cake
they want to drink
Nestle's Quik oh yeah cuz it's tasty
don't I don't have to do that no they
can get protein how many for short no
sugar
yeah what's up and it tastes worse
article cool so there's that or your kid
Molk Molk and then if you want like this
shirt that echos wearing this good shirt
it's a sec you know that our store
collectively everyone's today this is
not no because you keep calling it my
stores not my store what has your name
in it yeah no but everybody goes there
not just me in the store by myself New
York the store is for everyone yeah
that's true yes not your store is not my
story it's our store collectively as a
group the jack car store for yeah
absolutely
oh yeah yeah so that is that choco store
calm if you want to represent on this
path right just
freedom good mentality right looking for
the good in the bad quote-unquote bad
again it you know whatever you want to
represent us we get you hey Duff
speaking of which you were talking Chaka
white tea I don't know if you saw this
damn Tom Clancy fan that you are did you
see that in the latest Tom Clancy novel
the Jack Ryan you know what he drinks I
saw this yes I didn't read it but I saw
it somebody hosted about sure and put it
out there yeah Jaakko - yep Jack Ryan's
in the game
we're wondering what James Reese is
gonna be drinking it book yeah
definitely we'd always be we're like the
warrior kid a three book you know what
Noah Keys won't be nor origin nice yeah
boom there you go so yeah everybody's
representing so yeah you want to
represent even if you're already
representing you want to re represent
represent more chocolate store come boom
ladies t-shirts rash guards hats
everything patches everything subscribe
to this podcast so you can hear jack car
and others talking about their
experiences and then leave reviews so
that I can laugh at your funny reviews
or be like do you ever had not to your
computer like you're looking at your
computer you read you read a solid
review and you just give that review a
little a little bit not actually little
a head nod for that big good so me wrote
a damn good review the other day and I
read I was like you know gave him one of
those physical my computer is 11 o'clock
at night what am i doing reading reviews
trying to go to sleep you're talking
about how you've no problem going to
sleep some others I do know is I have
some trouble go to sleep well have
trouble going to sleep not wait it's at
it's trouble waking up oh yeah oh you
have trouble waking up yeah
I'd rather sleep in but I do get up but
well at 5:00 a.m. it comes quick yeah at
5 a.m. and 3 a.m. like you but 5 a.m.
meet the guys at 5:30
knock it out home at 7 help with the
kids then start writing you know that's
solid right there that's way too much
stuff for your crew up there nice get
them in the game awesome you say the
head nod that's like level one like like
what do you call like there's base level
respect right there's extra respect and
then there's the ceiling above the
ceiling there's level one respect when
your physical head nods for computer
yeah
level two claps claps for easy seams
then you clap for the for the performer
that's that's different bro no no I
would never in a million years clapping
like him I know cuz I don't think I
don't know bro level two but someone's
gonna come up with it like a review or
something and it'll warrant a cloud
that's that's my had a good one
yesterday little head nod yeah your
computer lay out somebody wrote Jack R
has a graduate degree in the art of war
Oh someone else had one right or mob
yeah no someone else wrote one about if
John wick The Punisher and somebody else
had a childhood be James Reese 2% yep
yeah man so yeah subscribe if you're
into it and you want already review do
it
also don't forget about where your kid
podcast which is not dead no it's it's
it's being resurrected well he's never
danced oh yeah resurrected oh yeah yeah
it is alive and well yeah however there
hasn't been a lot of new additions
lately but they're coming they're coming
boom there you go so I was I was
mentally going through possibilities for
the next story from Uncle Jake right so
yeah so the pendulum was just away yeah
yeah pendulums away from the corner kid
podcast yeah actually now that book 8 is
almost wrapped that's that's what the
that's what the prioritizing execute is
all just gonna say you beat me to it
waiting to get in there with pirate
execute yeah exactly
yeah so that's where a podcast in and if
you want to support a warrior kid then
you can get some tacos soap or your kid
soap for virus jokes ranch dot-com young
Aiden or your kid making soap and don't
forget about YouTube channel don't
forget to like subscribe and click right
what do they say I think this is like
subscribing no wait
yeah something there's some other thing
that you're supposed to do yes if you're
that okay so anyways cherry Tube channel
yeah that's it yeah yeah so if you want
to do those things whatever and that's
where you can get echoes echoes videos
that he spends on allegedly so much time
making balloons and they come out once
every every four years like the Olympics
in like the leaner Olympics in Park City
its it every four years a good video is
gonna come out whatever chat car likes
them so do every posted that 100 story
we lie to ourselves oh boom there you go
see thanks thanks for that by the way
also psychological warfare
go ahead no I'm giving it to you I put
your name there psychological warfare
you don't know what that is is what it
is an album with tracks choco chat
anyway he tea on those tracks he tells
you how to get through moments of
weakness like if you're about to eat the
wrong thing because for the short term
because the short game long game you
can't listen to this bro yeah and it
hundred-percent works by the way so if
you're like okay I'm gonna in life this
is what I learned it's one of the
biggest things people ask me this all
the time I would say literally anyone
who has questions quote-unquote for me
this is one of the questions they'll ask
what's the biggest thing you learned
from Darko I'll tell you right now here
it is if you look at things short term
versus long term small picture big
picture oh and then there's like another
one whatever but either way it's all the
same thing short term so in
psychological warfare if you're going
short game if you're gonna start playing
the short game for that moment this will
be this if you're gonna lose the short
game in the moment Oh as in if you're
gonna if you're gonna take a short term
out they're gonna have immediate
gratification but it's a long term down
yes exactly right and most of the time
not all the time but most of the time
short term if you play short short game
you lose the long game with that play
it's like you take a short term step
forward and take a long step back it's
one of those deals
usually you can break things down into
that so this is what this does I'm
getting that looks like I need to let
listen to that while I'm at Whole Foods
and I'm getting up there ready to get to
that register and they have those peanut
butter cups
oh the all-natural all-natural animal
that's okay
all that orange Reese's all-natural
heroin is all-natural that's perfect
actually because actually it's good
because you can actually have it in the
queue you know because a lot of times
like you're just in the pantry where
ever you are and you're like boom I'm
looking for the good stuff will it ever
boom I see that the Oreos bromine I
can't just go let me cue it up sometimes
it gets hard it's one thing bro my son
okay can drive now right which means he
can go to the store which means he can
shop for food right we're talking 16
year old boy what does he get at the
store Reese's just were so [__] a
show-off oh he just gets great you know
he'll be like I'm hungry
going to the store comes home what does
he come home with half gallon of
whatever ice cream makes sense right you
because you know supermarkets they they
they formulate or they design ya store
in the product or a certain way yeah so
like boom boom that's why they put the
Reese's Peanut right at the at the
checkout they comb impulse buys right
and that goes for everything little
magazines you know that is that's their
psychological warfare seriousness their
psychological warfare and you got to
combat that
with psychological chuckles I Club yeah
looks like they're for thanking me
they're flankin oh boy the aisle but you
gotta check out and that's why they got
them that's your weakness bro they're so
good but that's what your boy is
essentially falling for when he goes
that's where you're wrong you gotta
finish it by yeah
please leave the house that you think
the Breyers yeah okay these ants do yes
but these he goes and gets cakes like
you know the plan is obviously the ice
cream thing is really taking a down hit
at my house cuz mulk right cuz everyone
just kind of on the mulch I like but my
son will get straight up chocolate chip
cookies just that's what he did last
night that's why this is fresh in my
mind comes home
nine o'clock goes to the store at eight
forty like we already ate dinner okay
where are you going home it's gonna move
the store and he's only think about one
thing he's not thinking about lettuce
apples he's thinking chocolate chip
cookies coming back with the big chunks
in them like the premium yeah and then
red again for little kid brings him into
my house you don't mean it's a good way
to get shanked actually eaten a
psychological warfare hey if you want to
go visual visual psychological warfare
for yourself check out flipside canvas
calm my brother Dakota Meyer who's
awesome veteran marine incredible guy
started this company making art to hang
on your wall and you can it says cool
stuff on it like good like this
political freedom he's got a whole array
of different stuff so check that out
looks like canvas calm and if you want
him to make something tweet him yeah we
tweet Dakota Meyer say put this on a
canvas he'll figure it out you make it
happen
also on it so you gonna on it calm
sloshed choco this is where you can get
your kettlebells you're getting
kettlebells you don't on it oh yeah
there before do you guys work out the
home gym where you guys working out now
now we go down that it's really cool
they have a full-on
like CrossFit type setup at the gym and
there's an indoor track there it's it's
amazing it's full-on like CrossFit bang
and you can go and they leave you alone
yep tibalt
I was not there the other day and guess
what no chalk was allowed really no this
is Jim section we talked and talked
about
was it a hotel number it was a proper
gym hey it was a gym that had bumper
plates it was a gym that had six squat
racks you know more squat no six squat
racks I'm in this gym no chalk if they
have bumpers they have that everything
else no chalk
they had pull-up bars no charge that's a
real problem I can see like a you know
hey if you're a little our fitness and
you got the the the universal machines
or whatever that X is out there anyway
nothing gets universals by the way but
you know let's keep it real anyway
Banach kettlebells you see no more yes
so that's where I give my kettlebells
kettlebells routine in general is good
do kettle on yeah oh yeah what mobile as
far as your spine and whatever you're no
one's gonna ask you earlier but um what
is that like keep you from doing mainly
well I wake up but it hurts all the time
but every time I turn my head and I
realize just how lucky I am that after
20 years and all those things like
that's all I have to deal with so it's a
mobility it hurts whatever surgery but
c67 spine they were not no and the
military wanted to fuse me but luckily I
had got a second opinion and they went
in and shaved off a bone spur in there
that was crushing and nerves making my
left was like a frame anatomy I don't
think they've used that term that's what
I got but yeah see 67 got to go back in
there but every time it hurts I'm just
like you know there's guys out there for
PTSD TBI missing arms and legs just
destroyed and this is all I have you
know hey good good seriously that's yeah
absolutely so I'm gonna keep me from
joining it just reminds me so here's a
reminder that I'm very lucky very
fortunate so you can you can push it but
just not get nuts and yep really I still
got you know like keep try to keep up
and anything I'm trying to take it easy
on goes out the window just like let's
just roll it's just roll at 20%
I remember those yeah
exactly yeah not happening now so I
remember well yeah good then kettlebells
right my point was do you do kettlebells
you get that functional strength back
whatever boom non-p I mean your back
stop prohibiting boom you're into
kettlebells yup fit absolutely almost
every day when we're working out with
the crew oh yeah yeah all my kettlebells
all on it cannibals and I've got some
dogs if you want books if you like books
first of all the terminal list and True
Believer by Jack car check those out get
into the I believe you just said like
the psychological minefield of this dude
you know who's on the serious warpath
already dead yep get some way the
warrior kid three is out it's live and
you can get that on amazon.com where
there's a will is the subtitle of that
book find out what happens to young mark
how uncle Jay caps them out way the
warrior kid one and then way the warrior
kid two marks missions those are also
available Mikey in the Dragons you can
get that one for any kid between the
ages of 0 and 150 and they're gonna get
something out of it the discipline
equals freedom Field Manual get that
that's what you want to get your kid
that just graduate that's for trying to
get your employee that seems to be
sliding off the track that's what you
want to get your friend that is letting
themselves go down the slippery slope
yes
taking the short-term gratification on
stuff no you get them the discipline
equals freedom Field Manual the audio
version of that is on iTunes Amazon
music it's an mp3 format then there's
extreme ownership and the dichotomy
leadership where you can take these
lessons from combat me and my brother
lave Bab and wrote that book those books
and how you can apply those lessons to
your business to your life
we got a salon front leadership
consultancy and what we do is solve
problems through leadership we also have
EF online where you can you can continue
to Train leadership because you never
master it you never met you never even
really get good at it it's you always
have to be working at it so EF online
work at it work at it every day do you
what happens if you stop working out do
you stay in shape Echo Charles negative
what happens if you stop trying to
become a good leader same same thing you
go backwards get rusty first beyond
rusty yeah we're talking catastrophic
just lose it yeah yeah yeah that you
turn into a leadership slob yes you
don't want no you want to be sharp you
want to be in tune yeah I experienced
this because I get to see it all the
time with the companies we were like I
see someone that's like really in the
game and they're sharp yeah they're
there their leadership is sharp and then
all of a sudden they slack off for a
while and they have a leadership problem
and they handle it wrong right
just like they couldn't Mack they
couldn't do 42 pull-ups like they could
before now they're doing 32 why they
haven't been trained it got to keep your
leadership brain sharp you ever done 40
to pull them no I think my mine was 30
something was my was my best I think
it's still good high school when I was
very very light there are two sets of 20
I still remember that was my thing came
all that bike that's it that's what's
interesting if that was getting ready
for buds essentially that was high
school boom so I still had a little time
yes I'm still training what I was gonna
say is like for me getting ready for
buds was I was like oh I didn't I did
three sets of pull-ups today because we
didn't know I had to do 250 pull-ups per
workout right 350 pull-ups work I didn't
think of that
they didn't even make sense to me right
it was 19 it was 1989 1990 wow it was
there was no way to access this
information no so you're never gonna be
doing the same number of pull-ups as
your class number yeah yeah how many
that's what we're gonna do yeah by the
way we're doing it tomorrow after lunch
yeah so get some of that so that's the
same thing physical mental get your
leadership mindset sharp keep it sharp
EF online if you want to come to the
muster you better sign up now cuz
they're all sold out they all sell out
very quickly
Chicago sold out Denver's head in that
way that's September 19th and 20th and
then Sydney Australia looking forward to
that coming down and meeting ye all
people in Australia again if you want to
come to that extreme ownership calm and
then he F overwatch if you are looking
for someone in your company that knows
how to lead then check out EF overwatch
comm where we got special operators
combat aviation leaders that are
transitioning into the civilian sector
and can help you and your team using the
principles of combat leadership that we
read about in extreme ownership and
economy a leadership so EF overwatch
comm and if you want to hear more from
us give 500 hours of listening isn't
enough then we are on the interwebs
Twitter Instagram and Facebook echoes
out echo Charles I met Jacque when we
link in Jack is at Jack Carr USA echo
anything else nothing else Thank You
Jack car thank you guys so much for
having me on it's a pleasure to be here
I feel very fortunate that getting out
we were able to make the life we want on
the outside can defy a few odds along
the way and that's all because because
my life 19 coming over 19 years
I'll stay this month and and yeah so
because of her strength raising those
kids allows the way now I can tell about
a little bit hopefully not mess it up
gotta getting into her routine but yeah
she's amazing super strong lover with
all my heart my next this next mission
in life really is all about her and them
that's awesome well thanks once again
for coming on and obviously thanks for
your service to America as for healers
yeah you had an awesome awesome run and
you were deployed over and over and over
again and even though we joke about you
know what a good time it is and we did
have a good time I know you had a good
time but at the same time you know
you're making sacrifices your family's
home alone and and that's huge so thanks
to you thanks to your family thanks to
your wife for for having the strength to
deal with that and appreciate you and
and it's awesome to see what you're
doing right now thanks brother
appreciate it to anyone else that's
listening that is serving right now or
has served thanks to you for keeping us
free and to police and to law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
officers and Border Patrol and Secret
Service and all the first responders
that are out there 24 hours a day and
they're training and they're preparing
and they're on call so that we can be
safe here at home thanks to all of you
for that service and for that sacrifice
and to everyone else that is listening
remember that there's always somebody
out there with their sights on you it
may be it's a competitor in business
maybe it's an enemy insurgent maybe it's
some criminal thug maybe it's someone
that's just looking to do harm to you or
your family or maybe maybe that someone
is you then maybe you're your own worst
enemy sliding into the depths of
complacency allowing yourself to wander
down the easy path say no to that
remember why you're here remember what
you want to do remember your cause be a
true believer and then live that belief
by getting up every day then getting
after it and until next time this is
Jack car and echo and Jocko